Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch.
willkommen zu Chaos Radio 101.
Hallo.
In dieser Sendung werde ich nicht behaupten, dass es meine letzte Chaos Radio Sendung ist. Ich bin jetzt wieder da.
Das Thema heute ist Wir haben kein Netz.
Wir haben kein Netz. Ja, das ist ja immer so. Dafür haben wir ein Radio. Ich meine, das hat auch nicht jeder. Du musst auch mal lernen, ein bisschen bescheidener zu sein.
Wir haben ja zum Glück noch ein bisschen Papier.
Genau. Der Frank ist hier. Der Harald ist hier. Der verrückte Holger Klein. Wollen wir das Thema schon sagen oder muss ich erst die Geschichte mit den Millionen Pfund?
Nee, das kannst du auf die Musik drauf.
Dann mach ich mal die Musik an.
Am besten, dann wissen alle, wo drin wir sind.
Die kennt doch eigentlich auch jeder. Das ist trivial. Aber gut, The KLF ist eine legendäre Band, als Rave noch mit Gitarren war. Da haben die angefangen, Musik zu machen und haben sich vorgenommen, Popstars zu werden. Und zwar möglichst schnell. Haben auch ein Buch geschrieben, wie werde ich möglichst schnell Popstar und werde möglichst reich. Ich weiß leider gar nicht, wie das Buch im Original heißt. Und was sie gemacht haben ist, sie haben sich irgendwann, als sie dann auf dem Zenit ihres Erfolges waren, hingestellt und eine Million Pfund in echten Scheinen einfach verbrannt, um darauf hinzuweisen, dass es auch schon vor der New Economy die Möglichkeit gab, massiv Geld zu verbrennen und darüber zu lachen.
Das ist auch schon fast eine ganz gute Überleitung. Unser Thema heißt nämlich heute Wie viel für die Ewigkeit? Und soll sich beschäftigen mit allen Formen von Datenarchivierung, Datenträgern, Daten wegspeichern, Daten sortieren, Backups machen und einfach wie viel für die Ewigkeit archivieren und wie lange ist eigentlich die Ewigkeit und wie lange hält der ganze Kram von seinen Datenträgern?
Ja.
Chaosradio 101, was ist das? Ist das immer noch KLF jetzt?
Nee, das ist was anderes. Ich frage aber nicht, was?
Was? Tut mir leid. Es hätte mich interessiert. Darüber hinaus interessiert mich diese Sendung. Speichern.
Richtig.
Ist ja was, womit ich mich nicht so ausklappe. Ich speicher mal alles ab und dann formatiere ich die Platten.
Wir haben eigentlich überlegt, wir hatten irgendwie so ein bisschen einen Plattencrash und haben überlegt, so wie sortieren wir das jetzt eigentlich neu und was machen wir eigentlich mit unseren ganzen Urlaubsvideos, die anderthalb Stunden lang sind, die wir im Diffix-Format haben. Ungeschlittenen Urlaubszüge. Genau und so die Partys und was machen wir mit den ganzen Musik, die wir, es gibt ja viel freie Musik auch im Netz, die wir gespeichert haben, etliche Stunden. Und wie sortieren wir die am besten? Wie organisieren wir das? Wie machen wir, wie richten wir die Festplatten ein? Sind eigentlich Festplatten überhaupt noch der beste Speicher dafür? Wollen wir irgendwie die Sachen irgendwo weg sichern, auf DVDs brennen? Ist das überhaupt eine sinnvolle Sache? Und welches Format ist eigentlich das Beste für diese Videos und für die Musik? Und wie machen wir die vernünftig sortieren? Aber das heißt, gibt es da irgendwie, jeder hat seine persönliche Sortierung oder machen wir das alphabetisch?
Kannst du das überhaupt sagen, welches Format das Richtige ist? Also ich habe mit jemandem gesprochen von der DLR, der die EDV bei diesen ganzen Mondmissionen und Weltraummissionen und sowas betreut. Und der sagt ja, wir haben einfach Dateiformate, die sind 20, 25 Jahre alt, die kann keine Sau mehr lesen.
Ja, da gibt es eine ganze Menge Geschichten zu. Geschichten ist übrigens auch ein gutes Stichwort. Wir haben auch eine Mitmachseite. Wir machen das jetzt für jede Sendung. Wir haben in der Wikipedia, das ist verlinkt von unserer Homepage chaosradio.ccc.de, da gibt es eine Mitmachseite, wo unsere ganzen Links und ganze Feedback von der Sendung zusammengetragen wird. Und da empfehle ich euch einfach mal raufzugehen. Da sind jede Menge Links mit auch lustigen Geschichten. Und das gucken wir auch während der Sendung an. Das heißt, ihr könnt auch da eure Ideen und wenn ihr irgendwie Ergänzungen habt, tragt ihr die da ein. Und da ist im Wesentlichen auch die Sendung, wie sie jetzt stattfindet, festgehalten.
Was heißt, wir gucken das an? Haben wir Internet neuerdings?
Jetzt haben wir Internet.
Hey, dann können wir jetzt anfangen.
Gut, Freunde, wir klinken uns kurz aus, denn wir haben jetzt Internet. Radio könnt ihr ja alleine, nicht? Wie fangen wir an?
Willst du ein bisschen was zur Geschichte mal beantragen? Wo ist so das Urgestein? Seit wann gibt es eigentlich Festplatten? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Was gab es vor der Festplatte? Das fände ich viel... Also wie hat man denn zu Zeiten... also seit wann gibt es Festplatten?
Naja, also wenn man bei der Geschichte der Datenträger anfangen will, dann muss man eigentlich anfangen, also überhaupt bei maschinell verarbeitbaren Datenträgern, dann muss man wohl anfangen bei den Lochkarten, die also tatsächlich schon auch im Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts verwendet wurden in entsprechenden Rechenmaschinen. Und das hat sich dann eigentlich relativ lang gehalten, diese Möglichkeit, Daten auf Lochkarten zu speichern. Und auch die ersten Computer, die man dann verwendet hat, bis in sicherlich die 50er Jahre, 60er Jahre hinein haben, eben auch noch mit Lochkarten gearbeitet. Die ersten Bandlaufwerke waren tatsächlich auch mit Papierbändern oder mit Lochbändern. Das heißt, man hat dann die einzelnen Karten, die man in Karteikästen hatte, ersetzt durch Bänder, in denen Löcher drin waren. Da gibt es hier Zahlen, die sagen, in den 40er Jahren, und in den 50er Jahren kamen dann die ersten magnetischen Trommeln, magnetische Trommelspeicher zum Einsatz.
Wie funktionieren die technisch?
Na das Prinzip bei diesen ganzen magnetischen Datenträgern, die ist eigentlich seit damals immer das Gleiche geblieben. Also egal, ob man jetzt diese Trommeln anschaut oder ob man jetzt Floppy-Discetten, Festplatten usw. oder auch VHS-Recorder, das ist einfach so, dass man eine Beschichtung auf einem Band hat, die man magnetisieren kann.
Nee klar, aber wie wird das abgetastet? Also wie jetzt eine Wachswalze, also eine Spur, die dann durchgehend abgetastet wird? Oder wie funktioniert das bei so einem Magnet?
Trommel.
Bei den Trommelsparen muss ich sagen, kann ich nicht aufpassen. Also so steck ich nicht in der... Ja mein Gott, ich bin ja keine Archäologe.
Datenarchäologen.
Aber sind es nicht im Prinzip einfach tatsächlich magnetische Trommeln? Auch wie Festplatten, also im Prinzip die Scheibe nur als Trommel?
Vielleicht weiß das ja mal jemand und sagt uns Bescheid.
Genau.
03317097110, 03317097110, wie funktioniert eigentlich die Magnet-Trommel?
Ja, ich denke, das wird wohl eher umgekehrt sein. Also bei den heutigen Festplatten ist es ja, oder auch bei den Floppy-Discette usw. ist es ja so, dass die Scheibe rotiert und der Kopf sich darüber bewegt. Und da ist es... Also der Kopf wahrscheinlich innerhalb der Trommel und die Trommel rotiert außen herum bei der Art von Konstruktion.
Ach, wie eine Waschmaschine.
Naja, wie dem auch sei, jedenfalls hatten wir 1906...
Stopp, wir haben einen.
Ach, super.
Axel. Ja, Magnettrommeln. Ja, überhaupt gar nicht so unrecht. Funktionieren ungefähr so wie eine alte Edesannsalze. Es ist eine große Trommel, die von außen magnetisiert ist. Also muss man sich vorstellen, wie langer Tilender. Der von außen magnetisiert ist und von außen fuhr dann im Prinzip mechanisch gesteuert, also richtig noch mit Getriebe und Antrieb und nicht mit Schrittmutter wie heute. Ein Lesekopf drüber. Die Trommel rotierte dran vorbei.
Also wie ein Trommelscanner im Prinzip auch.
Genau. Übrigens Alternative gab's auf der anderen Seite hinter dem großen Zaun dasselbe auch als elektrostatische Speicher, mit Teflon noch Trommeln. Die sind als superschneller Cache-Speicher verwendet worden, die waren schneller als die Magnetkerne.
Was hat also draufgepasst? Hast du da so Größenordnungen?
Ja, 64k. Richtig viel, aber die Trommel war auch riesengroß, war auch Großrechner, also war nicht unbedingt so was für uns heute.
Was nennst du riesengroß?
50 cm oder so war die lang. Die passierte mit wahnsinniger Geschwindigkeit, aber fanden wir nicht mehr nach der Geschwindigkeit. BSM6 ist das Schlagwort dazu. Der Rechner, der irgendwie zur Errechnung der Raketenbahnen mal erfunden worden ist, Ende der 50er, Anfang der 60er Jahre. Also so noch zu Zeiten, wo das Ding begehbar war.
Ja, 1956 gab es dann die erste Festplatte, wie wir sie heute kennen, in der Art und Weise. Das ist die IBM 305 gewesen. Und ja, hat sozusagen vom technischen Aufbau her, kann man sich vorstellen, dass da 50 einzelne Platten tatsächlich waren, die jeweils 24 Zoll Durchmesser hatten, also entsprechende Größenordnung. Und die konnte dann eben 5 Megabyte speichern auf dieser Art von Platte. Hat gekostet, gab es gar nicht irgendwie zu kaufen, sondern man konnte nur leasen, und das kostete 35.000 US-Dollar im Jahr. Leasinggebühr.
Leasinggebühr.
Für 5 Megabyte.
Ja, gut, was kostet es, wenn man heute 5 Megabyte per SMS überträgt? Kommt doch nicht so hin.
Ja, also der erste Schritt hin zu den Festplatten, wie wir sie heute kennen. Es sind halt verkleinert worden.
Wer liest sowas? War damals schon abzusehen, dass ein Jahr später der doppelte Speicherplatz oder wie auch immer, in welchem Faktor das auch immer wachsen mag. Aber ich geh doch nicht hin und lese heute was für 35.000 Dollar. Verpflichte mich vielleicht darauf, das auch noch 5 Jahre lang zu machen oder so. Und nächstes Jahr kommt einer und macht was billigeres. Oder mit einer höheren Speicherdichte.
Ja, das wird natürlich so passieren. Du machst das natürlich, investierst dann, wenn du es gerade brauchst. Große Speicherlibraries, wo Bänder sind, wo viele Bänder sind, wo es ein Roboterarm hin und her fährt und die reinlädt. Das ist schon die Größenordnung, wo ich aber auch gerade das System eben aus diesen Gründen der Datensicherung einfach auch 10 Jahre behalten will. Auch völlig egal, ob es nächstes Jahr was doppelt so gutes, doppelt so schnelles gibt. Aber ich habe einfach gesagt, jetzt will ich das System haben und ich muss jetzt meine Daten für die nächsten 10 Jahre hier einlagern. Und deswegen liese ich das Ding jetzt für 10 Jahre und habe dann auch die Garantie, dass das Ding in Ordnung gehalten wird, entwegen meinem Servicevertrag und habe dann erstmal eine Sorge weniger. Man muss halt einfach mitrechnen als Firma, dass es im nächsten Jahr was billigeres und besseres gibt, aber sag einfach jetzt, ich will jetzt die Sicherheit haben und will einen kalkulierbaren Preis haben über die nächsten 10 Jahre. Das wäre so eine Variante, warum man so was machen könnte.
Ja, interessant ist eben bei dieser Geschichte jetzt ab dieser Festplatte, dass das bis heute das gleiche Funktionsprinzip ist. Man hat natürlich die Speicherdichte enorm erhöht, man hat die Größe dieser Platten verkleinert, die Geschwindigkeit erniedrigt und so weiter. Im Grunde ist es immer wieder das alte Schema von ich lasse eine Scheibe mit magnetisierbarer Oberfläche rotieren und bewege darüber einen Kopf, mit dem ich eben entweder Magnetisierung vornehmen kann oder eben bereits erzeugte Magnetisierung auslesen kann. Interessant ist auch, was wahrscheinlich nicht so viele der Zuhörer wissen, ist, dass die Festplatte vor der Floppy-Disc erfunden wurde. Heute spricht ja kein Mensch mehr von Floppy-Discs. Wer verwendet heute noch irgendwelche Disketten? Das ist ja schon fast Museums live, aber tatsächlich ist die erste Floppy-Disc 1971 vorgestellt worden in der Computerbranche. Also doch ein ganz deutlicher Schritt von 1956 zu 1971.
Warum heißt eine Festplatte eigentlich Festplatte? Kann das irgendjemand ergründen? Also woher kommt dieser Name? Es gibt irgendwie im Englischen Hard-Disc, was ja nicht unbedingt Fest.
Ja, aber Personal Computer wird auf Deutsch auch mit Personal Computer übersetzt, was auch der totale Schwachsein ist.
Also meine Festplattes machen auch Sinn im Sinne von, dass die Platten fest eingebaut sind. Also im Vergleich zu einem Wechselmedium, zu einer Floppy-Disc.
Ich würde nicht auf den festen Einbau schließen, sondern ich würde sagen, dass das Medium selber fest ist. Weil die Floppy ist eine lappige Scheibe und Hard-Disc ist eben das, was tatsächlich fest ist. Damals haben die Dinger ja hauptsächlich eher Winchester Drive geheißen und nicht irgendwie Festplatte. Das kam wohl daher, dass bei IBM der Codename für das Projekt damals irgendwie Winchester war. Ich kann mir das noch gut denken, Ende der 80er Jahre, als ich mit Festplatten zum ersten Mal auch persönlich zu tun hatte, da hat man auch noch so Leute gefunden, die das tatsächlich Winchester Disc nannten. Auch in den Typenbezeichnungen WD, sonst irgendetwas. Ja, Winchester Disc oder Winchester Drive. Ja, ja, ja.
Chaosradio 101, das Chaosradio der Datenspeicherungen. Harald ist gerade noch bei der Geschichte des Datenspeichers, physikalisch.
Genau, wir waren bei der Winchester stehen geblieben.
Die Winchester.
Genau.
Ach herrlich. Ich kann nicht mal meine tratbare Winchester bei dir anschauen. Das finde ich total geil. Ich will das jetzt in meinen aktiven Wortschatz einfließen lassen, damit ich auch wie ein echter Nerd wirke.
Ja, das wirkt auch. Also ihr werdet lachen, aber ich hatte zu tun mit so alten Diplom-Ingenieuren, die dann da auch in der EDV zu Gange waren. Und das war dann so das Markenzeichen dieser alten EDV-Elite, sag ich mal, dass die in solchen Begriffen geredet haben. Das hat auch heute noch die Mainframe-Leute, die heute noch mit Großrechnern zusammen, die haben auch ganz eigenartige, da heißen Festplatten DASD, also D-A-S-D, zum Beispiel. Die haben dann ganz eigenen Chargon dafür. Da bootet man auch kein System, sondern man IPLt das. Die haben also eine ganz eigene Sprache.
Was heißt denn das in Lang?
IPL, Initial Program Load.
Ah, und DASD, was?
DASD, ja D-A-S-D. Oh Gott, das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr auswendig. Schade. Guck doch einfach mal bei Google.
Ja, aber ich hätte es früher auch mal gefunden.
Na, ich bin ja keiner von diesen alten Mainframe Leuten.
Ah, jetzt hast du dich selbst geoutet. Na ja, das kann ich dir jetzt auch nicht mehr sagen, warum wir das sagen. So, was?
D-A-S-D.
Gut, wie dem auch sei, wurde dann 1976 zum Beispiel die erste 5, 25 Zoll Mini Floppy Disk vorgestellt. Das sind also diese 5, 25 Zoll Disketten, die Leute, die einen C64 hatten, zum Beispiel die, wenn sie sich gut an die erinnern können, auch Leute, die PCs, sagen wir mal, vor 1993 vielleicht oder so in Gebrauch hatten, die werden auch noch 5, 25 Zoll Disketten kennen.
Ich belege die ganze Zeit, wozu hatte man bei den 5, 25 Zoll Disketten noch diesen Locher?
Das waren die 5, 25 Zoll Disketten, die waren ja nicht so hart Plastik wie die jetzt, sondern die waren so schwabblig weich, also eher wie so ein Briefumschlag so dick ungefähr. Und da konnte man an einer Seite in ein Loch rein knipsen. Das waren halt Kodierungen über die Speichermöglichkeiten. Das eine war der Schreibschutz und das andere war, glaube ich, was die Rückseite, was die Rückseite benutzten konnte.
Und wie gesagt, das vorgestellt worden 1976 im August, hat damals gekostet 390 Hohes Dollar als Aufmerksamkeit. Ja, dann geht das also so ein Stückchen weiter. Irgendwann kamen dann auch die 3, 5 Zoll Diskette dazu, die wurde vorgestellt 1980.
Erst noch die 3 Zoll gab es auch noch.
3 Zoll?
3 Zoll Schneider CPC.
Schneider, der hatte eine 3 Zoll Diskette?
Der hatte eine 3 Zoll Diskette.
Ich weiß noch, mein Schulfreund Knut, der hatte einen CPC 464.
Ja, aber nicht vor 1980.
Nein, das war später.
Eben, die 3, 5 Zoll Diskette wurde 1980 vorgestellt. Double-Sided-Double-Density, mit 875 Kilobyte unformatierter Kapazität.
Wie viel?
875 Kilobyte. Da blieben dann irgendwie so 720 Netto davon übrig, wenn du es formatiert hast. Ja, gut, dann geht die Entwicklung ebenso weiter mit den unterschiedlichen Standards. 1982 gab es zum Beispiel die 5 Megabyte Winchester Disk Drive für den IBM PC, die früher nur 2000 USD verkauft wurde. Also eine 5 Megabyte Winchester Disk. Dann hat Sony eine neuere Version von dem 3, 5 Zoll Floppy Drive vorgestellt, 1983. Und auch 1983 noch, da hat sich wohl viel getan. In dem Jahr wurde die CD-ROM nämlich entwickelt. Also die Weiterentwicklung der Audio-CD-Technologie für die Verwendung als Datenspeicher-Medium für Computer-Daten statt von Musik. So, ja, dann kann man die Geschichte so anschauen. Es gibt immer wieder so eigenartige Ausläufer der Datenspeicher, wenn man sich überlegt, es gab von den 2, 5 Zoll, es gab erst diese Double-Density, dann die High-Density, dann gab es auch mal ED, Extended Density, die sind 2, 88 Megabyte.
Hab ich nie gesehen.
Die hat nur IBM in irgendwelche PS2-Rechner eingebaut, die außerhalb von irgendwelchen Firmien eigentlich nie jemand zu Gesicht bekommen hat.
War doch eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Ja sicher, aber das war halt zu spät, würde ich mal sagen. Also so spät, wie die das eingeführt haben, da hat sich dann keiner mehr für kapazitätsgesteigerte Floppis intusiert. Genauso wie Zip3 von LS120 und was das alles gab, das hat ja auch nie so eine weite Verbreitung gefunden wie Floppy.
LS120 sagt mir auch nichts, also Zip hatte ich selber noch.
LS120 ist im Prinzip so ein Konkurrenzprodukt gewesen, auch zeitgleich auf den Markt gekommen wie Zip mit 120, war aber so physisch kompatibel.
Ich glaube, man war nicht abwärts kompatibel zu normalen Floppys.
Genau, du kannst einen LS120-Laufwerk, kannst dir auch normale 3, 5 Zoll HD und DD-Floppys reinstecken. Das ist also der Unterschied gewesen, hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Du kriegst heute, wenn du einen Rechner irgendwie neu kaufst, ein PC oder so, dann sind da immer noch diese popelalten 3, 5 Zoll Floppys mit 1, 44 Megabyte drin. Das möchte man eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht mehr sehen.
Entschuldigung kurz, Axel hat einen Einspruch anzumelden hier. Was denn?
Die 2, 8 der Floppys gab es auch woanders. Die hat Stack in seinen ersten Alpharechnern verbreitet. Und die gab es auch in den Wechseln teilweise. Ich hab eine Wechsel mit einer 2, 8 der Floppys.
Hast du auch Floppys dazu?
Ja, ein paar. Zwei oder drei.
Ist das noch in Betrieb bei dir?
Die Wechsel geht noch, klar. Allerdings, das Floppy-Laufwerk hab ich, weiß ich nie mehr, ob's noch geht. Aber die Wechsel geht noch. Die läuft mit Openform S62 oder so. Was? Noch was, über das Floppys fällt mir grad ein. Angefangen hat das natürlich mit den großen, netten 812-Floppys, ne? Mit, die irgendwie, was, 170k oder so was hatten, ne?
1971, ja genau, mit Eisenoxid.
Vielleicht ganz kurz, die Leute, die die Maßeinheiten nicht auf dem Sprung haben, 1 Zoll sind 2, 54 Zentimeter.
Ja, genau.
Ich erinnere mich, das gab es auch mal im Videobereich, gab es mal U-Matic. Das ist ungefähr so die 8, wahrscheinlich die 8 Zoll Diskette des Videorecorders.
Es gibt ja noch die Zollbänder und so was, die sind ja fast vergleichbar mit den großen 1 Zoll, die großen C-Matzen. Wir waren stehen geblieben bei CD-ROMs, genau.
Wundersame Speichermedien, die es auch noch gab.
Genau, um jetzt dann mit der Geschichte so ein bisschen in die Neuzeit auch zu kommen. 1990 sind die ersten CD-ROM-Laufwerke mit 150 kilobit pro Sekunde Datenübertragungsrate vorgestellt worden. Das sind also die, wo man heute irgendwie 50- oder 52-fach kauft. Dann ist es eben 52-mal diese alte damalige Übertragungsrate. Und ja, bei den Festplatten ging es tatsächlich eben einfach immer nur kleiner, kleiner, schneller, schneller. Es gab dann...
Kleiner im Sinne von Größe, also von der Bauform.
Bauform kleiner, das heißt erst die 5, 25 Zoll Festplatten, 3, 5 Zoll Festplatten, dann die 2, 5, die man in Notebooks überall findet. Mittlerweile gibt es die 1, 6 Zoll Platten, die man in MP3-Playern verbaut. Das wird also einfach die Bauform immer kleiner. Was natürlich kombiniert damit, dass man die Datenrate ständig steiger dazu führt, dass, obwohl die Bauform kleiner wird, die Kapazität größer wird.
Das Magneto-optische Laufsatz, und damit haben wir jahrelang gesendet.
Oh, es gibt Worms, es gibt alles mögliche. Man kann ja nicht alles erzählen.
Das kenne ich wenigstens, dachte ich.
Das sind eigentlich schöne Medien. In so mission-critical Umgebungen werden die schon noch gern verwendet, weil sie eigentlich wirklich robust sind. Also Minidisc ist ja zum Beispiel das gleiche Prinzip. Du kannst einfach deine Cola rüber kippen, dann wäscht du die ab und dann geht es dir nach trotzdem wieder. Das ist an sich eine ganz schöne Sache.
Stimmt.
In Fritz in Brandenburg an der Havel, dann 102, 6.
Eine nach 11. In der Nacht gibt es viele Wolken und stellenweise immer mal wieder Regen. Das bei Tiefstwerten zwischen 9 und 3 Grad. Morgen wird es meist heiter, nur ganz selten soll es mal regnen. Die Höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen 14 und 20 Grad. Und die Meldung gibt es jetzt mit Matthias Kackers.
Bundesregierung und Gewerkschaften wollen die Weiterbildung arbeitsloser Jugendlicher verbessern. Dafür soll eine Expertengruppe aus Vertretern des Wirtschaftsministeriums, der Bundesagentur für Arbeit und der Gewerkschaften gebildet werden. DGW-Chef Sommer wisst darauf hin, dass allein in Berlin zehnmal mehr Jugendliche in ein Euro-Jobs stecken als in Ausbildungsmaßnahmen. Die Förderung der Ich-AGs wird bis Ende 2007 verlängert. Das beschloss das Kabinett in Berlin. Ursprünglich waren die Zuschüsse nur bis Ende 2005 geplant. Arbeitslose, die ihre Existenzgründung fördern lassen wollen, müssen allerdings mit einer strengeren Kontrolle der Erfolgschancen rechnen, heißt es. Der Großflughafen Schönefeld kann frühestens im Jahr 2011 und damit ein Jahr später als geplant eröffnet werden. Das teilte die Flughafen Schönefeld GmbH heute mit. Hintergrund ist der vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht verhängte vorläufige Baustopp. Morgen findet der fünfte sogenannte Girls Day statt. Über 125.000 Schülerinnen haben sich angemeldet, um einmal in bisher typischen männlichen Berufen sich umzuschauen. Über 6.800 Einrichtungen von der Werkstatt bis zum Ministerium öffnen dafür ihre Türen. Auch Fritz ist bei dieser Aktion dabei. Der Verkehr auf Fritzer 10, südlicher Berliner Ring, Dreieck Potsdam Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Genshagen und Rangsdorf. Nach einem schweren Unfall mit mehreren Fahrzeugen liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Und A24 Berliner Ring Richtung Pritzberg zwischen Kremen und Färberlin. Gefahr durch einen Fußgänger, bitte Vorsicht.
Vielen Dank Matthias, drei Minuten nach halb elf.
Neu auf Fritz, Mixtape à la carte, die Fritz Koch Show. Zum Mix hören und mitkochen. Immer mit einem Kochprofi, seinem Rezept und seiner Musik. Diesmal direkt aus der Küche von Sabine Lengert aus dem Anna Blume. Mixtape à la carte, die Fritz Koch Show. Zum Mix hören und mitkochen. Immer samstags ab 18 Uhr. Fritz.
Chaosradio 101, das Chaosradio der Datenspeicherung ist es, was ihr hört. Frank, Harald und Holger im Studio. Ich hab jetzt mittlerweile rausgefunden, was DASD heißt. Und zwar Direct Access Storage Device. Erklärung kommt. Gerät für den direkten Speicherzugriff. Mit einem Datenspeichergerät der Kategorie DASD kann man direkt auf Informationen zugreifen, ohne sich über alle Speicherbereiche sequenziell bis zum gewünschten Element durcharbeiten zu müssen. Während es sich bei einem Diskettenlaufwerk um eine DASD-Einheit handelt, ist das beim Magnetbandgerät nicht der Fall, da hier die Daten als lineare Blöcke gespeichert werden. Weiter bitte mit der Geschichte.
Ja, wir waren ja eigentlich schon so ziemlich am Ende angekommen, dessen was man heute so gängigerweise als Massenspeicher noch einsetzt, ist ja die Festplatte nach wie vor unbestritten. Wenn es um große Datenmengen geht, ist es einfach durch die hohe Kapazität, die man hier für relativ wenig Geld mittlerweile bekommt. Festplatten sind gängig mittlerweile in Kapazitäten 300, 400 Gigabyte erhältlich, für nicht viel Geld. Es ist auch interessant, die Entwicklung sich anzugucken. Es ist also tatsächlich in den letzten 25 Jahren konstant so, dass jedes Jahr sich die Speicherdichte um 60 bis 100 Prozent pro Jahr erhöht. Das heißt, jedes Jahr bringt man auf die gleiche Grundfläche an magnetischer Speicher, also an Oberfläche Datenträger, bekommt man 60 bis 100 Prozent mehr drauf. Dass eben konstant über die Zeit hinweg ist, ist schon eine ganz schöne Leistung. Natürlich gibt es mittlerweile ganz andere Speicher, insbesondere die Flash-Speicher sind da zu erwähnen, die eher so im mobilen Bereich eingesetzt werden. Da hat man MP3-Player mit Flash im Handy, hat man Flash-Speicher, Flash-USB-Sticks.
Genau, als USB-Sticks bekannt.
Genau. Ja, dann kannst du ja mal dein Handy in USB-Post...
Warum eigentlich nicht, verdammt noch mal? Das fehlt noch am Firlefon, aber das ist nicht die Sendung.
Du hast doch Blauzahn am Telefon, was willst du noch?
Egal. Manchmal hat man eben auch keinen Blauzahn zur Hand. Wenn man zum Beispiel zu blöd ist, sich das in sein iBook einbauen zu lassen, wenn man es kauft. Ich will jetzt niemanden angucken.
Dann gibt es aber blautsänige USB-Sticks.
Ja, stimmt, habe ich ja dann auch gekauft. Können wir das Thema wechseln?
Ja, Flash-Speicher. Da ist der Unterschied, dass man eben nicht auf magnetischen Oberflächen irgendwas magnetisiert, sondern man hat einfach Halbleiter-Technologien. Das ist eigentlich eine Weiterentwicklung aus dem sogenannten EPROM-Bereich. Das sind Speicher, die man elektrisch zunächst nur beschreiben konnte einmal. Bei so einem EPROM werden die dann gelöscht mit einer UV-Lichtlampe. Das heißt, man muss die mit ultravioletten Licht bestrahlen. Das hat man dann weiterentwickelt zu den sogenannten E2, der E-Quadrat-PROMs oder EEPROMs, die Electrical Erasable Programmable Read-Only-Memories, bevor er mich wieder fragt, was das eigentlich heißt. Diese EEPROMs hatten dann eben den Unterschied, dass man sie auch elektrisch wieder löschen kann. Das heißt, es sind grundsätzlich Speicher, die ich einmal beschreiben kann und dann elektrisch komplett löschen. Und danach kann ich sie eben nochmal beschreiben und nochmal und so weiter.
Wie sicher ist es eigentlich? Also ein Flash-Speicher.
Ein Flash-Speicher ist schon ganz gut. Es gibt aber natürlich das Problem, dass ein Flash-Speicher nicht unbegrenzt häufig wieder beschreibbar ist. Das heißt, der ist natürlich über eine gewisse Lebensdauer. Wenn ich da jetzt täglich von meiner Diplomarbeit, die ich gerade schreibe, irgendwie einen Backup mache, dann ist das absolut das richtige Speicher-Medium dafür. Aber das ist jetzt sicher nicht geeignet. Das machen auch gerne in der Unterhaltungselektronik oder in kleinen Geräten machen das Firmen auch mal falsch. Das ist zum Beispiel bei einer Setupbox Daten, also bei einer Fernseher, beim Digitalreceiver, zum Beispiel Daten, die jede Sekunde kommen oder alle paar Sekunden kommen, in diesem Flash-Speicher auszusehen, abspeichern, weil da irgendwie mit der Software was falsch läuft. Dann ist das Ding ziemlich schnell hin. Das kann schon mal passieren.
Also man kann da typischerweise so zwischen 10.000 und 100.000 Schreibvorgänge im Moment im technisch machbaren einstufen.
Aber wie ist es, wenn ich was langfristig speichern will? Wahrscheinlich kommen wir da sowieso früher oder später noch mal zu. Also ist das das Medium der Wahl oder will ich es lieber auf einer CD haben, auf einer CD brennen?
Also USB-Speicher sind von der Kapazität her nicht so groß. Das heißt, sie sind wahrscheinlich eher für Zwischenlagerungen geeignet. Und sie sind natürlich auch relativ teuer im Vergleich zu einer CD-ROM. Also ein Flash-Speicher kostet, also ein USB-Stick kostet für, naja, lass es. Das kostet den 256 Megabyte liegen so bei 25 Euro ungefähr. Und dann kannst du halt schon ein paar Rohlinge auch verkaufen.
Wie lange hält das? Also wird es den Rohling überleben oder wird es den Rohling nicht überleben? Das ist die Frage, wenn ich es beides in den Schrank lege.
Na ja, also bei Rohlingen, da kommen wir auch noch später zu, bei CD's ist zum einen die Haltbarkeit an sich der Daten da drauf. Das heißt, wenn die einfach irgendwo rumliegen, dann ist das ein Problem. Zum anderen ist aber auch gerade die mechanische Belastung ein Problem bei den CD-ROMs. Das heißt, wenn man gehört, es gibt jetzt Laufwerke mit 52-facher Geschwindigkeit und diese Scheiben drehen da drin einfach so dermaßen schnell und sind in so einer hohen mechanischen Belastung ausgesetzt, dass es einfach auch schon mal passieren kann, das wäre nur ein minimaler Materialfehler, ist irgendwie eine ganz kleine Ungenauigkeit im Material oder eine Unwucht. Das heißt also, dass ich da einen Aufkleber drauf gemacht habe, irgendwas beschriftet habe oder der Aufdruck irgendwie sehr ungleichmäßig ist, dann zerspringen die Dinge einfach im Laufwerk auch mal, auch schon vorgekommen. Oder sie zerkratzen ganz einfach, ich lasse sie runterfallen, die fallen ungünstig und einfach hinüber.
Also bei CD's da gibt es unendlich viel, was da passieren kann. Also es geht ja an von Sonnenlicht ist ganz schlecht, hohe Temperatur ist auch schlecht. Also man muss sie eigentlich dunkel und kühl lagern und nicht so, dass sie irgendwie mechanisch belastet werden. Also am besten irgendwo hängend in irgendwelchen Umschlägen oder so. Ja nicht liegend, dass sie sich übereinander stapeln und gegenseitig Druck ausüben und so weiter. Es geht bis hin, das ist tatsächlich so eine schöne Artige Anekdote, dass es je nachdem, in welchem Land, was für einem Gebiet du lebst, es gibt auch mittlerweile einen Pilz, der die organischen Strukturen von CD-Rohlingen angreift. Jaja, selbstverständlich. Also in Brasilien zum Beispiel, da tritt so was tatsächlich auf. Aufgrund der hohen Luftwichtigkeit und hohen Temperatur. Das kann bei gepressten CDs natürlich nicht passieren, aber das ist die Struktur, die du beschreibst mit dem Laser und die du veränderst, das ist ja eine organische. Organische Strukturen sind gegen Dinge wie Pilze zum Beispiel nicht immun.
Wir haben Fragen an euch oder eine Frage vor allem. Wir wollen nämlich eure größte Datenverluststory hören. Also wir reden ja heute gerade über Speicherung, Daten, Festplatten und so. Ist euch schon mal eine Festplatte kaputt gegangen? Was waren denn die schlimmsten Daten, die ihr verloren habt? Habt ihr schon mal CDs gehabt, die euch im Laufe der Zersprung sind oder beim Runterfallen kaputt gegangen sind? Oder habt ihr einen bösen, bösen USB-Stick aus, wir sind im Klo runtergespült?
Oder einen bösen Bruder, der euch die Magnetfuß-CB-Antenne auf die Diskettenbox gestellt hat, oder was weiß ich?
Die Magnetfuß-CB. Macht eigentlich noch jemand CB?
Das reicht auch, wenn du deine Diskettenbox einfach auf den Lautsprecherbox stellst, weil es da so bequem gut steht.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Mir hat mal jemand erzählt, dass der Magnetstreifen der EC-Karte sich auch mal ganz gerne löscht, wenn man zu viel klingendes Handy daneben liegen hat.
Das halte ich für ein Gerücht, aber es gibt diese Waren-Sicherung in Kaufhäusern, diese Clips, die werden auch magnetisch entsichert. Deswegen sind da auch ganz große Aufkleber drauf, dass man da nicht seine EC-Karte oder Kreditkarte drauf legt.
Also eure Herbst-Datenverlust-Geschichte unter 0331 70 97 110. Ihr könnt euch auch gerne Pseudonym melden, damit wenn ihr dann dafür ausgelacht werdet, dass euch vielleicht beim Sinken eures iPods ein kleines Detail verloren gegangen ist. Damit das nicht auf euch zurück steckt in eurem privaten Leben. 0331 70 97 110. Was ist denn so eure Herbst-Datenverlust-Geschichte?
Eine schöne Herbe Datenverlust-Geschichte hat sich die Deutsche Bahn erlaubt. Die hat nämlich in den Tischien, in den Interregio oder Intercity-Zügen war es, ICE sogar. Die haben die Tische waren mit so Magnet-Klips, also zum Hochklappen. Also die Tische oben, dass sie so hängen bleiben. Da waren halt Magnete drin. Genau, der Sitz, also den ich halt vor mir hab, den Tisch vor mir. Und ist natürlich ganz blöd, wenn ich da meinen Laptop rauf stelle, weil die Laptops nach Regel genau da, die Festplatte hatten, wo diese Magnete waren.
Genau, links unten im Eck oder links, also links, rechts unten im Eck, ja.
Und da hat dann die Bahn sich tatsächlich lange dagegen gewehrt, hat behauptet, nein, also die magnetischen Flussdichte dieser Magneten werden viel zu gering und hin und her und so weiter. Und dann erst dadurch, dass so viele Leute Probleme bekommen haben und Daten verloren haben und dass die CT, also die Zeitschrift, damals dann interveniert hat und da Gutachten und was weiß ich was, dann irgendwann sind diese Tische umgeändert worden.
Wahrscheinlich hat auch niemand Daten verloren, das war nur ein, die haben jetzt gesagt, jetzt ist mal die Gelegenheit, die kann ich verklagen auf 100 Millionen Schadensersatz.
Das ist ja mal geil.
Und haben sich dann irgendwie eine Geschichte ausgedacht, aber da waren diese blöden Magneten im Tisch.
0331 70 97 110, Datenverlust, Anekdoten, private oder die, von denen ihr mal gehört habt, seid ihr eingeladen an der Fritz-Hotline abzuliefern. Ich weiß auch noch, ich weiß, wir haben ja vorhin schon mal überlegt, wem das passiert ist. Es muss irgendein Kollege hier bei Fritz gewesen sein, der sich ein iPod gekauft hat und hat dann also offensichtlich übersehen, dass wenn man den iPod simpt, auf dem iPod immer genau das ist, was auch auf der Festplatte ist und niemals umgekehrt. Es sei denn, man wendet einen Trick an, aber den kannte der Kollege nicht, hat dann eben seine gesamten CDs gerippt, hat das mit dem iPod gesimpft, hatte dann alles auf dem iPod, hat sich gedacht, Mensch, jetzt kann ich ja mal hier mein Betriebssystem neu aufspielen. Ich formatiere erstmal alles weg. Hat dann seinen Windows Rechner alles wegformatiert, seine MP3s waren weg, die waren ja auch noch auf dem iPod, alles installiert, ein frisches iTunes aufgespielt, den iPod gesinkt und dann hat er scheiße geschrien.
Dann hat er die leere Festplatte nämlich auf den iPod gesinkt.
0331 70 97 110. Chaosradio 101, das Chaosradio ist datenspeichernd und wir würden uns gerne an der Fritzotline unter 0331 70 97 eins an euren krassesten Datenverlustgeschichten hören. Ich hab auch noch eine, das ist nicht gerade Datenverlust, sondern wir sind ja öffentlich rechtlich hier und hier dauert alles ein bisschen länger. Also ihr erinnert euch dran sicherlich, wie lange wir hier noch auf 311 gearbeitet haben, bevor es dann durch NT abgelöst wurde, die dann ein halbes Jahr später erklärt haben, dass es nicht mehr supportet werden wird. Damals gab es wenig Speicher und hier gab es dann diesen Mail Server und da war ein bisschen Speicher drauf und irgendwann hat eine Kollegin, deren Namen ich jetzt nicht nennen werde, eine Grafik geschickt gekriegt, die war 4 MB groß. Das ist mein Ende der 90er, da waren 4 MB ja noch relativ viel Zeug und die hat dieses Ding an alle geformt, sodass dann binnen Minuten dieser Mail Server komplett voll gelaufen ist und nichts ging mehr. Also über Tage dann natürlich. Dann hab ich gesagt, ja dann geht doch einfach schnell rüber ins Sterncenter hier in Potsdam, kauft ein bisschen Festplatte und die haben gesagt, ja ne ist hier bestellt. 0331 70 97 110 eure herbsten Datenverlustgeschichten. Axel, unser einziger Hörer offensichtlich.
Zu Zeiten, da ich noch Systemadmin von einer kleinen Abteilung war, habe ich es geschafft mal die kompletten Mails meiner Abteilung, also alle, nicht nur die aktuellen, sondern alle Mailordner meiner Abteilung mal zu kanalisieren.
Kanalisieren, du meinst den Kanal runterzuspielen?
Ja, ja, in die digitale Nirwana zu schicken. Durch richtig Prasslichkeit. Ich hatte die Daten auf einem Mirror-Set auf einer externen Platte, also meine lieben Kollegen arbeiteten schon alle mit irgendwelchen Windows-Geschichten, aber aus Sicherheitsgründen hatte ich die ganzen Daten auf einem Pass-Works-Mirror-Set auf einer Deckmaschine, weil ich da relativ sicher war, dass ich da mit vielen Backup und zwei gespiegelten Platten eigentlich auch ganz gut lebe. Ja, und da war mir eine Platte von dem Mirror-Set kaputtgegangen. Und ich hab die falsche rausgezogen und ausgetauscht. Ich hab die neue reingesteckt, dann hat er sich synchronisiert, natürlich.
Das ist ja fast die iPod-Geschichte.
Ich wollte grad sagen, du warst das mit dem iPod.
Das ist die iPod-Geschichte, ja. Man sieht das den Platten dummerweise nicht anders. Das waren damals schon solche netten, hot-swappable Platten. Da hab ich die falsche rausgezogen. Und dann hab ich halt auf die kaputte Platte synchronisiert.
Und Backups gab's natürlich auch keine.
Ich hatte eins. Ich hab's schon wieder eingespielt. Aber das dauerte schon so seine Zeit. Ich hatte als Backup damals so ein nettes DDRS-1-Band hier, diese DAT-Bänder. Und ehe sich das dann alles vorsichtig wieder auf die Platte gelegt hat, verging schon ein halber Tag. Meine Kollegen waren ein bisschen genervt. Ich auch. Also als ich dann feststellte, obwohl ja, du hast jetzt die falsche rausgezogen, da stand mir dann schon der Schweiß auf der Stirn.
Hattest du mal vorher geübt, dieses Backup zu machen?
Ja, das habe ich damals mal gemacht, als ich den Cluster neu aufgesetzt habe.
Weil das ist nämlich, das kenne ich auch ganz oft mal von Firmen, die denken, wir haben ja alles auf Backup, kein Problem. Und wenn dann halt mal wirklich was passiert, entstehen sie da so, haben wir eigentlich dann noch irgendwie diese Software noch mal irgendwo anders? Ja, genau.
Die Backup Software sollte dann auch so ansteigen. Glücklicherweise ist das im VMS ja mit drin. Das ist nicht so schlimm. Da kann man vom Band tatsächlich zurücklesen.
Das Wichtigste bei Backups ist tatsächlich in der Tat immer einfach der Restore-Test, dass man versucht, das einfach mal zurückzuspielen und zu gucken, ob alles da ist.
Richtig, ja.
Und die Lagerung natürlich auch.
Und die Lagerung der Bänder. Man sollte nicht von der Hand weisen, dass Bänder wesentlich empfindlicher sind als beispielsweise Papier. Und so. Auf Papier lagern Daten wesentlich sicherer als beispielsweise auf Bändern.
Ja, das hat die NASA auch schon mal spüren müssen, wie wir wissen.
Erzähl, erzähl, erzähl. Erzähl.
Ich oder unser Anhörer?
Du hast angefangen, du erzählst was.
Ja, naja, da gab's aus den 70er Jahren, vor allem auch noch aus den 60ern teilweise, gab's also von Mars-Sonden Daten, die nach 25 Jahren bei der NASA verschollen bzw. verschwunden gegangen sind. Die hatten sie also auch auf Bändern gespeichert damals und haben offensichtlich hatten da keine Policy, oder es ist übersehen worden, das mal umzukopieren auf moderne Medien. Und dann irgendwann hatte man gar keine Laufwerke mehr für die Bänder. Und selbst als man das Problem gelöst hat, wusste man mit den Formaten der Daten auf den Bändern gar nichts mehr anzufangen, weil die nicht dokumentiert waren, die Datenformate von damals.
Das ist eben so liart für die NASA.
Aber da hat man im Prinzip wirklich all die Probleme in einem Fall, die man bei dieser ganzen Archivierung eben sieht. Man hat zum einen das Problem, dass die physikalischen Formate sich ändern. Das heißt, es gibt ständig neue Disketten, Festplatten, Bänder, sonst irgendwas formatisch, so rein von den physischen Abmessungen, von den physikalischen Parametern her. Und zum anderen auch die Formate, in denen ich Daten ablege. Also Dokumenten, Formate oder was auch immer, die ändern sich ja ständig. Es gibt immer wieder neue. Und wer kann denn heute noch mit irgendwelchen obskuren Daten von vor 20 Jahren oder so noch was anfangen? Das ist ja schon schwierig. Da braucht man dann irgendwelche Impfortfilter oder Konvertierungssoftware usw. usw.
0331 70 97 11 0. Eure Herbstendaten Verlust Geschichten.
Also meine Herbstgeschichte ist hier. Ich bin ja Hobby Programmierer und die Bundeswehr musste ich gehen und meine Schwester war so schlau und hat meine Boxen genau neben meinen Computer gestellt. Und in den Monaten, wo ich sie in der Bundeswehr taktäglich benutzt, mit meinen Boxen gleichzeitig zusammen und der ganze PC in den Arsch gegangen.
Ja, also da haben wir dann das Problem mit dem Magnetfeld für die Zuhörer, die jetzt nicht verstehen, warum das ein Problem ist. Das ist einfach das Magnetfeld der Lautsprecher, das hier sozusagen die magnetischen Datenträger wie Festplatte und so weiter eben einfach überschreibt bzw. löscht.
Das habe ich mich richtig drüber gefreut, alles was drauf war, war weg.
Alle Programme, die ich in der Zeit da geschrieben habe und alles, alles weg.
Hab ich mich wirklich drüber aufgeregt.
Vor allem als junger Mensch, Jugendlicher, Schüler, was auch immer, kann man sich ja gar nicht leisten, überhaupt irgendwie Backups zu machen, weil man das Geld dafür nicht hat.
Dann ist es für mich immer noch alles nochmal neu. Aber das Beste war immer noch daran, dass das Scheißwein noch endlich weg war. Und hab das dann schön durch den Becken gewechselt.
Das war ein weiser Entschluss.
Hast du denn daraus gelernt, machst du denn jetzt Backups?
Ja schon und ich hab auch daraus gelernt, dass das Zimmer, in dem mein PC steht, mittlerweile immer abgeschlossen ist, wenn ich nicht da bin. Das ist die sicherste Methode, es zu schätzen.
Danke dir, gute Nacht. Ja, jetzt geht's rund Datenverlustgeschichten.
Ja, da auch, Entschuldigung. Mich hat mein Kumpel gezwungen, hier anzurufen. Ich hab mich auch ganz schlau angestellt, hab mir schön auf meinen Rechner so versteckte Laufwerke, mit so Steganuss, sagt euch das was? Sicherheitsprogramm schön verschlüsselt, schön hoch verschlüsselt, weil ein bisschen Paranoia-Ohler dabei, so die Chefs-Unterlagen so drauf. Na ja, und dann irgendwann ist die Festplatte komplett abgeraucht, und dann waren die Festplatten natürlich, die externe sozusagen oder die da integrierten, natürlich schön versteckt und schön verschlüsselt und das war's, war weg, war's.
Ende der Vorstellung.
Und dann waren die Daten alle weg. Alle von wo?
Dann musste ich mir alles nach und nach halt wieder besorgen, waren.
Wegverschlüsseln ist auch gleich das, oder?
Ja, genau, der Schlüssel war komplett im Eimer und ja, daraus habe ich auch etwas gelernt.
Alle drei oder viermal weglesen, nicht nur einmal, und nicht nur auf jeder Platte.
Na ja, das war auf jeden Fall sehr schön.
Danke Thomas. 0331 70 97 110, eure Herbst- und Datenverlust-Geschichten jetzt hier mal im Chaosradio 101. Dominik.
Ja, und zwar bei mir war das schon eine Weile her zum Glück. Da hatten wir noch eine 20-Gigabyte-Festplatte und wir hatten einen neuen PC gekauft, ein 120er drin und wollten ein unbedingtes alte Betriebssystem, also wollten den ganzen Couch rüber kopieren, und die Daten natürlich Windows dann darauf gezogen und das haben wir mit Norton Ghost gemacht. Norton Ghost hat ja diese tolle Angewohnheit, die Partitionen auch vollständig zu kopieren und hat selbstständig Größen eingestellt und dann hatte ich also praktisch zwei 55-Gigabyte-Partitionen auf der 120er, eine 55-Gigabyte große C-Partition. Und naja, gut, das war am Anfang erst mal nicht so schlimm, aber dann nach und nach vollgepackt und irgendwann, kennt man ja Windows, wo er gerade gesagt hat, scheiß Windows, ist der Quatsch irgendwann in den Bauch runtergegangen und dann waren 55-Giga auf C weg.
Aber wer braucht auch eine 55-Gigabyte große C-Partition?
Das ist echt mal geil.
Ja, das war das, was uns danach auch oft gefallen wird, nachdem wir das mit Morton Ghost alles kopiert hatten.
Aber das stimmt, da muss ich mich auch mal dazu bekennen, so meine ganzen Datenverluste, die ich hatte, sind alle durch irgendwelche Umsortieren, Neu-Partitionieren, Vergrößern, Verkleineraktionen eigentlich entstanden. Oder hat man denn da doch irgendwie mal die falsche Partition erwischt oder irgendwie das Partitionenvergrößern, so ein Resizing ist irgendwie schiefgegangen. Oder irgendwie war da das falsche Dateisystem und dann dies und hm. Also es waren halt nicht so mechanische Geschichten, dass die Festplatte kaputtgegangen ist, sondern wirklich eigentlich mehr durch so eine zu gewagte...
Windows ist gar nicht böse. Du machst das nur immer falsch, Frank.
Wo er gerade gesagt hatte, mit diesen alten Dateiformaten, die nicht mehr erkannt werden, da gab es letztens eine Sendung, ich weiß jetzt nicht mal, wo es lief, es war gegenüber alte DDR-Stasi-Akten. Und da war das dann auch, dass die vollkommen eigene Programmier- und Auslesesprachen hatten und sie jetzt einen Berg von einzelnen Nullen haben und damit nichts anfangen können, weil eben die Programme zur Auslesung nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem. Also, um auch wieder auf die NASA zurückzugreifen, die kaufen ja auch teilweise gebrauchte, uralte Hardware ein, um überhaupt noch kompatibel mit solchen alten Systemen und solchen alten Formaten zu sein. Und den alten Standards zu entspannen.
Hoffentlich sind sie dann aber auch so schlau, die Sachen auch dann auf was Aktuelles zu kopieren.
Wenn's budgetiert ist, dann wird das auch klappen. Vielen Dank Dominik. 0331 77 97 11 0. Frank?
Frank?
Der ist doch im Studio, der Frank. Der kann doch gar nicht...
Frank, was ist denn mit dir? Gut, dann kümmern wir uns im Weiteren um Alex, nicht der.
Ich hab auch noch eine kleine Anekdote. Und zwar gab's damals für den AmiA so einen kleinen Stecker, womit man Backups auf einem Videorecorder machen konnte. Was, was, was, was?
Jetzt wird's...
Oh, jetzt wird's...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch jemand kennt von euch.
Ja, wir haben einen Stecker, mit dem man Backups auf dem Videorecorder...
Na ja, das hat man in den Videoausgang reingesteckt.
Oder ich glaub sogar noch in den seriellen dazu, ich weiß nicht, wie das genau war.
Und dann hatte man einen SCART-Stecker, den hat man dann in den Videorecorder reingesteckt und konnte auf einem ganz normalen VHS-Kassette Datenbackup machen. Und wenn man sich das auch angeguckt hat auf dem Videorecorder, also auf dem Fernseher, da war das im Endeffekt schwarze und weiße Punkte, die immer hin und her gesprungen sind.
Das ist das, was beim WDR Computer Club oben am Rand immer mitgelaufen ist, oder was?
Ein ähnliches Prinzip, aber also nicht ganz, das war glaube ich die Austauschlücke, was die damals gemacht haben. Nee, da ist es halt schon auf dem ganzen Bild, wie Informationen einfach. Also letztendlich ist es ja eigentlich nur der in Anführungszeichen Hightech oder der größere Bruder von der sogenannten Datasette. Auch C64 gelegt, ist halt einfach auf normale Audiokassette, wurden damals Daten gespeichert. Kann man auch prima am Radio senden, hat glaube ich damals DT64 gemacht. Ja. Da gibt es auch einen Klassiker, ich habe ihn dabei, von Atari Frogger, von...
Activision ist das, oder?
Nein, es gibt von... 5 Sterne Deluxe Werfteln. Es gibt irgendwie so einen ganz, ganz Klassiker. Haben wir schon zu oft gespielt, aber wo jemand im Radio anruft und sagt, ich wünsche mir Frogger von der Gruppe Atari.
Das war wieder völlig an mir vorbeigegangen.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall, die ganze Sache ist damit geendet, dass der Chip da drauf oder diese Verbindung da drauf auf diesem Kabel ist kaputtgegangen. Und die Firma gab es nicht mehr und da hab ich angefangen rumzulöten und es ging alles nicht mehr so richtig. Und dann, ja, damals hatte sich die Sache erledigt, die Backups konnte ich nicht mehr auslesen. Und ja, ich hab im Nachhinein immer noch Bänder gefunden, wo dann halt schwarze und weiße Punkte immer wieder drauf waren.
Kannst du mal hier im RBB Fernsehen für eine neue Nachtschleife anbieten oder so?
Das liest ja noch jemand aus.
Die habe ich damals um die 1000 Mark bezahlt.
Das waren 20 Megawatt für eine Amiga.
Das war halt, also diese Video-Lösung, ich kann mich da auch noch gut dran entsinnen, es gab es für Amiga, es gab es auch für andere, zu dem Zeitpunkt, es war halt eine billige Lösung, wo man sich als Schüler oder was auch immer eben gerade noch leisten konnte. Ja, ein Video-Decoder hat man rumstehen oder hatten die Eltern einen und dann ging das halt.
Gibt es aktuell auch modern für DV-Kassetten, wo ich dann auf meine DV-Video-Kamera die Sachen auch über Firewire rausspielen kann. Ja, wobei das da nicht mehr ganz so abwegig ist. Also ich meine, letztendlich ist ja DAT, also DDS als Speicher im Prinzip auch...
Digital Audio-Tape.
Genau. Das wo Leute Musik speichern, kann es ja genauso, ist mehr oder weniger anerkannt, ist mittlerweile vielleicht nicht mehr so aktuell, aber war vor ungefähr fünf Jahren, zehn Jahren so in dem Dreh, schon ein sehr wichtiges Datenspeichermedium.
Das ist auch noch... DDS 4 wird schon auch eingesetzt. Mit 24 Gigabit pro Band, glaube ich.
Wobei ich kenne Leute, die nur fluchen darüber.
Und wo Frank angesprochen hat, bei den Firewire-Cameras mit dem DV, ich meine, die Firewire-Cameras, also die DV-Cameras, die zeichnen ja sowieso digital auf. Das ist ja was anderes als bei den alten VHS-Tapes, wo das analog gespeichert wurde. Und auf so einem DV-Band, da kriegt man schon, wie viel sind es, 8 GB, so was?
Ja, 8, 9 GB drauf. Letztendlich ist es ja nur ein Bitstrom, der auf der DV-Cassette gespeichert wird. Das sind auch nur Nullen und Einsen. Und was du da speicherst, ob du da jetzt, keine Ahnung, MP3s draufspeichert, oder DV-Videos oder HD-Videos oder so. Das ist ja nur die Sache, wie denn nachher die Sachen komprimiert sind. Also kommen wir noch später zu. Ja, kommen wir später vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu.
Ah so.
Eine Minute nach 23 Uhr ist Chaosradio 101. Das Chaosradio der Datenspeicherung nennen wir es doch einfach mal. Und wir wollen gerade eure schönsten Datenverlustgeschichten hören. Da gibt es ja viele Geschichten. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen. Christian aus Eberswalde.
Hallo. Also ich hab was zu erzählen, dass ein Kumpel von mir der saß vor dem Rechner bei mir und hat mich gefragt, wie man bei Linux einen Ordner löscht. Ich natürlich gut gläubig gesagt RM minus R. Ja, genau und einmal waren 30 Domains den Bach runter. Alle samt weg.
Das heißt, der gute Mann war Admin irgendwo bei einem Provider.
Ich bin Admin und er saß bei mir am Rechner und hat an einem SSH-Window gesessen und hat damit 30 Domains über den Jordan gejagt.
Und natürlich ohne Backup?
Natürlich vor einer Woche einen Backup gemacht.
Immerhin.
Backups mach ich wöchentlich.
Immer noch jetzt?
Ja.
Aus Schaden wird man klug normalerweise.
Du möchtest jetzt nicht den Namen dieses Hosting anbieten?
Ich könnte den jetzt sagen, aber wäre das Schleichwerbung? Nein, nein.
Ja, wöchentliche Backups, das ist natürlich gefährlich.
Also alle Leute, die ich kenne, haben sich jetzt angewöhnt, nach dieser Story, haben sich angewöhnt, tägliche Backups zu machen.
Das ist gar nicht dumm. Danke, Christian. 0331 77 97 110. Eure heftigsten Datenverlustgeschichten bitte. Micha aus Seelo.
Also ich bin jetzt nun kein Fachuser, wenn man das so sagen möchte. Aber ich hab mir im Jahre 2000 von meinem Jugendweihgeld ein PC gekauft. Der hatte damals 750 MHz und eine 20 GB Festplatte. Das war so ein Komplettsystem von Hurricane, falls das jemand was sagt. Was auch immer. Und ich saß vor dem Rechner und das war eigentlich mehr so eine Art Spiele-PC. Und auf einmal hat das ein ganz grässliches, krachendes Geräusch gegeben, alles stockte plötzlich und was ich letztendlich rausstellte ist, wie das von Schauwit erwähnt hattet, die CD im Laufwerk zu sprungen. Das Miese daran war, dass ein Teil von der CD das Gehäuse des Laufwerkes durchstoßen hatte.
Und steckte bei dir im Schienenbein.
Es steckte praktisch quer auf den Prozesse und hat dadurch einen wahrscheinlich riesigen Kurzschluss ausgelöst. Es gab nur noch Dampf. Nachdem es anfing zu rauchen, habe ich schnell noch den Netzdecker gezogen und dann war es hin. Das war auch nicht ganz so nett. Dann habe ich das eingeschickt. Der kam wieder zurück mit einer Entschuldigung und zwei Wochen später passierte mir das noch mal.
Von welchem Hersteller waren die Rohlinge?
Das war ein bandäubiges Sony-Rohling. Also gar nicht mal so übel. Dann sagte man mir am Telefon, ja. Und bei Rohlingen kam dann die Wissen, schlechte Qualität und so weiter und so fort. Und ich meine, gut 32-fach Laufwerk, aber trotzdem, es war schon ärgerlich.
Das höre ich jetzt zum ersten Mal. Heute Abend zum ersten Mal. Das CD ist wirklich so.
Im Freund von mir ist das auch passiert.
Ein Freund von mir hat erzählt, dass es nur bei einem von 10.000 Laufwerken passiert. Und wenn es dann noch das zweite Mal ist, dann erhöht sich die Quote natürlich dementsprechend.
Ich müsste noch mal die Umlaufgeschwindigkeit, also die Umlaufgeschwindigkeit am äußeren Ende von so einer CD, die ist so immens hoch, das ist wirklich... Man kann die nicht mehr, also CD-Laufwerke sind bei 52 oder wo auch immer man stehen geblieben ist jetzt, sind die stehen geblieben, weil du einfach physisch das nicht mehr schneller drehen kannst, ohne dass es die CDs alle zerreißen würden.
Zu große Reibung dann einfach?
Nein, zu große Fliehkraft innerhalb der Scheibe. Innerhalb der Scheibe, die Kräfte, die da auftreten, das ist also Wahnsinn.
Und du hast auch noch ein Unwuchtproblem, das heißt, wenn du irgendwie einen Aufdruck hast, der ein bisschen kräftiger ist, dann fangen die Dinge auch irgendwie minimal an zu eiern.
Ja, das wollten wir damit auch nicht gesagt haben.
Selber schuld.
Nein, um Gottes Willen. Aber gerade früher gab es es ja auch häufig, dass man bei Audio-CDs mal etwas, wie soll ich sagen, avantgardistischer Reformgebung der CD hatte. Also so eine Kreissäge oder so.
Shape-CDs.
Wie auch immer man das nennen mag. Und tu mal sowas in den modernen CD-Raumlauf bei General Rechner um. Dann kannst du es aber gleich in die Tonne hauen.
Ich hab noch sowas von Stargate, die Stargate-Titelmusik als Shape-CD. Probieren wir mal aus irgendwann. Display gucken. Markus. Was ist das für ein Geräusch bei dir?
Ja, ich sitz im Serverraum gerade.
Du hast Datenverlust.
Nee, hab ich jetzt gerade nicht. Ich bin seit meinem Datenverlust ein bisschen paranoid.
Entschuldigung, das ist doch ein Staubsauger dabei hier im Hintergrund.
Nee, das sind ein paar Server halt, die hier laufen. Und ich setz gerade ein neues RAID 5 System auf. Ich wollte nur kurz meine Geschichte erzählen. Ich hab also einen Kundenrechner neu aufsetzen wollen und hab also die Daten erstmal gesichert über das Netzwerk auf den Server, auf meinen Server. Und weil ich da von vornherein schon ein bisschen paranoid bin, hab ich also die Daten drüber gesichert mit einem Tar halt und einem ZIP. Und bin dann auf den Hauptserver an die Konsole gegangen, hab die Sachen getaggt alle im Midnight Commander und wollte gucken, ob die Dateigröße gleich groß ist.
Wir übersetzen das dann gleich nochmal alles.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich schaff mal ein bisschen im Internet.
Nein, nein, das ist...
Ich versteh kein Wort.
Der typische Hörer kann wahrscheinlich mit Tar und Midnight Commander das jetzt anfangen.
Ich wollte ja gucken, ob die Dateigröße gleich groß ist wie auf dem Kundenrechner. Hab halt alle markiert, alle Dateien, alle Archive, sag ich mal. Das wollte ja wohl jeder verstehen. Und bin dann auf den Kundenrechner gegangen, hab die Installation angefangen und bin dann rüber auf den Hauptserver und wollte, weil ich ein Archiv ausgepackt hatte, dieses Archiv löschen. Bin also mit einer Kommande auf das Archiv gegangen und drücke löschen. Dann hat er natürlich angezeigt, willst du alle markierten Dateien löschen?
Klar.
Und weg war's.
Also übrig war das ausgepackte Archiv, alle anderen Daten waren weg. Und ich habe einige Gigabyte Daten vernichtet bei. Hab aber zum Glück sofort geschaltet und alle Prozesse gestoppt. Und dann kam eine 36-Stunden-Schicht Datenrekord zu Jann.
Ja, das ist eben genau auch ein ganz springender Punkt. Wir haben da später noch vor, einen Datenrettungsexperten zu interviewen am Telefon live in der Radiosendung. Weil man ja, wenn man gleich sofort nach dem Löschen eingreift, den Allerlege sehr, sehr viel wiederherstellen kann.
Also ich hatte zum Glück damals noch ein Extended-To-File-System drauf. Und da konnte man noch einiges, also ich habe im Prinzip alles wiederbekommen. Aber ich musste halt sofort alle Prozesse, vor allen Dingen Körnerlogging und alles halt stoppen. Und da habe ich zum Glück gescheitert, wie ich im Nachhinein, also normalerweise würde man ja abscheiten, alles abscheiten, aber das wäre genau der Fehler gewesen. Beim nächsten Buten wären die Daten weg gewesen. Also ich konnte die Daten zum Glück rekonstruieren, aber es war mein absoluter Datengau.
Danke Markus.
Viel Erfolg beim Raid aufsetzen.
Erklären wir uns später auch noch ein bisschen was zu was ein Raid eigentlich ist.
Unkund namens Jens aus Ilmenau.
Also eigentlich wollte ich erst mal nur auf ein Problem hinweisen, aber mir ist noch eine kleine Story darin eingefallen.
Was ist das Problem?
Und zwar ist das Problem bei den großen Festplatten, dass man eigentlich gar nicht mehr weiss, wohin man sichern soll. Also alles auf eine andere Festplatte. Ansonsten gibt es eigentlich gar nicht groß, noch eine Weile, wenn man irgendwie seine großen Partitionen hat.
Nicht für privat bezahlbares Geld.
Also 200 Gigabyte kannst du mal nicht, klar kannst du auf DVDs brennen, dann hast du halt ein Wochenende zu tun. Das machst du aber auch nicht. Ansonsten Bänder, das sind mittlerweile Größenordnungen, die echt nicht mehr bezahlbar sind für private, die einfach so unverhältnismäßig teuer sind. Das ist halt wirklich einfach das Sinnvollste, einfach eine zweite Festplatte zu nehmen und die dann irgendwo, weiß nicht, beim Freund zu lagern. Oder wir machen es bei uns in der Firma, wir gehen halt ins Bankschließfach, da sind es Länder für zwei Wochen.
Ja, so beim Freund oder eben der Bank, beim Ulan. Die andere Sache, die Story, die mir noch eingefallen ist eigentlich auch, die mein Hass auf das Ketten noch so verstärkt hat, auf verrottende das Ketten, war ich bei Freunden, die hatten Probleme mit ihrem Computer und da hab ich den halt neu aufsetzen wollen, hab das da auch gemacht und vorher noch deren Dokumente mit irgendwelchen Vorträgen und Studien-Sachen und so weiter auf das Ketten gespeichert, weil die halt nichts anderes hacken. Und die Daten haben auf eine das Ketten gepasst, hab die aber jeweils auf zwei das Ketten gespeichert, also zur Sicherheit noch eine andere das Kette. Und als ich die dann wieder aufspielen wollte, ging keine das Kette mehr. Das war dann schon bitter, aber die hatten alles zum Glück ausgedruckt. Und naja, da ging es dann. Das sind nicht alles so.
Die Ketten sind sowieso ein sehr unintegres Gespeichermedium, oder?
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen her, aber das war wirklich bitter. Leider.
Ich hab letztens bei mir beim Aufräumen ein paar das Ketten gefunden, hab gedacht, krass, die alten OS7-Disketten, Word 3 für Macintosh und so was drauf, hat auf drei Disketten verteilt. Und dachte mir, das schiebst du mal rein, da ist überhaupt nichts mehr passiert. Also die waren alle im Heimat.
Ja, das ist aber häufig auch das Problem, wenn man es nicht genau mit dem Laufwerk wieder ausliest, mit dem es geschrieben wurde, weil die alle eine Toleranz haben mit der Spur. Und wenn du das eine Laufwerk hat, die Toleranz ein bisschen links, das andere ein Stück rechts, dann geht es schon wieder nicht mehr. Also das ist jetzt bei dem Zuhörer natürlich nicht, bei dem Anrufer natürlich nicht der Fall gewesen, weil es ja das gleiche Laufwerk war, aber man hat häufig beides Ketten eben genau mit dieser Toleranz Schwierigkeit.
Auch bei Wandlaufwerken.
Aber was ich da auch schon festgestellt habe, dass so Ketten von Mitte der 90er irgendwie noch besser halten als die späteren, die dann irgendwie Ende der 90er zu verkaufen waren. Und die müssen Ende der 90er dann wirklich eine räudige Qualität gehabt haben. Weil die am ersten kaputt gegangen sind.
Ja, naja, das Ketten sind einfach völlig unredival. Ich bin froh, dass ich meine C64er das Ketten sammeln und irgendwann ausgelesen habe, als irgendwie die noch lesbar waren. Worauf hast du es jetzt? Die liegen jetzt alle als Disk Images auf einer Festplatte und ich hab meinen C64 Emulator.
Michael aus Berlin.
Ich muss erst mal sagen, ich bin so der alles andere als Auskennner am Computer. Ich hab vor ein paar Wochen von einem Freund seinen ausrangierten 1.8er-Medion-Rechner bekommen mit XP drauf. Und wie ich so bin, probier ich halt rum und habe jetzt letztens, war aus langer Weile, ich hab ja gesagt, ich brauch nur zum Spielen und so, hab ich versucht irgendwie Platz zu schaffen. Da hab ich so ein schönes Programm auch noch gefunden mit so einem kleinen rennenden Hündchen. Ich weiß nicht, welche Firma das ist, ist egal. Zum Ordnung machen, sauber machen, Datenmüll entfernen und so ein Kram. Hab ich halt auch hier und da gemacht. Unter anderem hab ich auch die Funktion gefunden, doppelte DLL-Dateien entfernen. Was für ein böses Lachen kommt. Diese lieber lassen. Ja und dann hab ich gedacht, wie es bei anderen Sachen auch so ist, bietet mir dann Fenster an, wo erscheint, die und die doppelten Dateien gefunden, wollen sie sich löschen oder nicht. Hab ich gedacht, ja. Hab ich also erst mal das Ding gestartet. Dann sah ich schon die Balken fliegen, darunter die vielen kleinen Buchstaben, die mir die ganzen Dateien anzeigten, wie sie so gelöscht wurden nach und nach. Und dann hab ich schon gesehen, oh, ai ai ai, irgendwas mit Win 32, DLL. Und da hab ich gedacht, da geht grad was schief.
Ja.
Und danach ging nix mehr, ne?
Ja, und man ist nicht mal mehr boten.
Ja, natürlich, ja. Und dann hab ich gedacht, so um 1 Uhr, im Moment, da war doch irgendeine CD, die ich mit dem Computer mitbekommen habe, packst du die mal rein. Ja, und dann hab ich dann das gemacht, dann hab ich auch versucht, das wiederherzustellen. Aber ich habe, wie ich jetzt inzwischen weiß, wird die falsche Option gewählt. Und dann bin ich mit dem Gedanken, Schlafengang, aha wunderbar, dann hast du wahrscheinlich diese, und das hat er vorher auch angezeigt, diese Rettenexe-Datei wahrscheinlich auch kaputt gemacht. Dann hab ich gedacht, naja, wenn man der Libereis anruft, der wird sich freuen. XP rettungslos kaputt gemacht, sowas hat vielleicht doch keiner geschafft. Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Moment mal, du warst noch nicht mehr in der Lage, das von CD zu booten?
Ja, dachte ich, als Nicht-Auskenner. Ich hatte drei Optionen, ich hab einfach die falsche Option gewählt, und dann hat er keine Daten finden können. Dann hab ich gedacht, jetzt ist es Zeit, schlafen zu gehen. Jetzt ist es eigentlich um 6.00 Uhr.
Vor allen Dingen Zeit, sich mal ein Handbuch zu kaufen. Doch, doch, doch.
Einfach Zeit nehmen und das lesen, was da drauf steht, und dann einfach die richtigen 1, 2 und 3, die richtigen Ziffer wählen. Das hab ich heute Abend gemacht, oder heute Nachmittag gemacht, und das Ding läuft ja wieder jetzt.
Glückwunsch und schönen Abend noch, Michael.
Ich weiß jedenfalls nie wieder DLL-Dateien lösen, wenn ich nicht genau weiß, was die machen.
Man sollte grundsätzlich nichts löschen, von dem man nicht weiß, was es ist und was es tut.
Na ja, die kleinen Regler unten.
Ja, jetzt schwimmst du wieder an deinem Regler rum, ja? Du kommst ins Spiel, der umgekehrt hat, Regler rum. Chaosradio 101 um Datenschmeichelung geht es heute Abend. Wir haben die Amine gerufen.
Genau, wir haben jetzt einen Experten, hu hu hu, am Telefon, den Vic aus Hamburg. Und der Vic arbeitet als Datenrettungsexperte. Ist das so richtig in einer Datenrettungsexpertenfirma?
Ich würde mal sagen, ich mache da aber im Wesentlichen Forschung und Entwicklung, das heißt also, aber ich beschäftige mich auch durchaus mit konkreten Fällen.
Dann kannst du uns mit Sicherheit sagen, was eigentlich an so einer Festplatte kaputt geht, wenn der User mal nicht schuld ist. Also das gibt es ja auch, die Festplatte ist jetzt drin, hat irgendwie fünf Jahre wunderbar funktioniert. Und ich mache morgens den Rechner an und das Ding macht nichts mehr. Also es kommt zumindest nichts mehr von der Festplatte. Und die Festplatte macht komische Geräusche, so Klack Klack oder Brrr Brrr oder so Sachen. Was geht eigentlich da kaputt an so einer Festplatte?
Naja, so eine Festplatte ist ja eigentlich, würde ich mal sagen, in dem ganzen Rechner das komplexeste Teil. Denn die hat ja, sage ich jetzt mal, erheblich viel mehr mechanische Teile als alles andere in dem Rechner. Ich meine, die dreht sich mit sehr hoher Geschwindigkeit. Die hat mehrere Lager, hat Magneten drin und Motoren und weißer Teufel. Und ein Stück Elektronik ist natürlich auch noch drin. Und dann, damit das Ganze dann auch noch sauber zusammenspielt, ist da auch noch eine ganze Menge Software mit auf der Festplatte drauf, die da im Spiel ist. Das unterschätzen die meisten Leute, dass so eine Festplatte eben auch wirklich megabyteweise Firmware hat, also Steuerprogramm.
Und für wie lange ist so eine Festplatte ausgelegt? Also gibt es da so Durchschnittswerte? Wie lange die so halten in meinem PC zu Hause? Oder wenn sie jetzt in einem Server auch die ganze Zeit laufen?
Also es gibt da nur sehr theoretische Werte. Also die Hersteller geben ja immer diese Meantime Between Failure an, das was du irgendwie so ungefähr dem Anwender sagen soll, ob das jetzt eine Festplatte ist, die für einen längeren Einsatz gedacht ist oder ob das eine Consumer Festplatte ist. Und ansonsten, da jetzt mal die Erfahrungswerte, die haben eine dermaßen hohe Streuerung, dass man das nicht, also es kann durchaus sein, dass so eine Festplatte zehn oder zwanzig Jahre läuft, ohne zu mutten. Es kann aber eben auch nicht sein.
Ist es für eine Festplatte gesünder, wenn ich sie täglich ein- und ausschalte? Oder ist es besser, wenn ich sie einfach laufen lasse? Also jetzt mal vom Stromverbrauch in Energiegeschichten. Hat man in der letzten Sendung mal abgesehen, aber allein für die Durabilität der Festplatte?
Ja, da gibt es unterschiedliche Dinge zu berücksichtigen dabei. Das eine ist, dass es Platten gibt, die für den Dauerbetrieb gebaut sind. Und es gibt Platten, die also vom Design her für den Desktopbetrieb gebaut sind. Und bei denen rechnet man natürlich damit, dass sie öfter mal außer Betrieb sind. Insofern hat das also erstmal eine Komponente, was der Hersteller sich dabei gedacht hat. Dann gibt es natürlich verschiedene gegenläufige, wie soll ich sagen, gegenläufige Antworten. Beispielsweise der mechanische Verschleiß ist natürlich etwas, was mit zunehmender Betriebszeit eintritt. Und auf der anderen Seite ist bei bestimmten Konstruktionen von Festplatten landen die Köpfe auf der Plattenoberfläche, wenn ich die Platte ausschalte. Das ist nicht bei allen so, aber bei einigen ist das so. Und da ist natürlich öfter das An- und Ausschalten schädlich.
Aber ich dachte, das ist mittlerweile, das habe ich seine Erinnerung von vor 10, 15 Jahren, da gab es noch diese Parkposition, wo man den Festplattenkopf parken musste. Das heißt, er wurde wie der Tonarm bei der Schallplatte dann am Rand abgelegt auf so einem Ständer. Ist das immer noch so? Ich dachte, das ist mittlerweile kein Thema mehr.
Das gibt es immer noch. Wobei man sich selbst eben früher musste man selbst dabei oder selbst dazu beitragen. Und heute machen die Festplatten das alles voll automatisch. Das heißt, man braucht sich damit nicht belasten. Aber es gibt durchaus welche, die im ausgeschalteten Zustand ihre Köpfe auf der Oberfläche parken. Meistens in einer in der inneren Medienzone. Das heißt also, die wird mit Lasern aufgeraut, sodass der Kopf dort also nicht kleben bleibt. Also dass er nicht nicht, wenn er jetzt irgendwo auf der Datenrohberfläche stehen bleiben würde, dann würde er da so festkleben, dass die Platte nicht mehr wieder losdrehen würde. Und deswegen raust man eben diese Zone besonders auf, damit der Kopf dort nicht haftet.
Okay, wenn mir jetzt so ein Datengau passiert, sei es jetzt durch eine Festplatte, die kaputt, also mechanisch, also elektrisch kaputt ist, oder durch irgendwie einen Bedienungsfehler. Und es sind jetzt extrem wahnsinnig wichtige Daten. Ich habe keine Backups und das sind jetzt, weiß nicht, irgendwelche Forschungsergebnisse. Dann kann ich so etwas in einer Datenrettungsfirma geben. Und das ist aber, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, ziemlich teuer. Kannst du da mal so eine Größenordnung nennen? Also wenn jetzt mein Wagen ist, keine Ahnung, das Haus abgebrannt oder halb abgebrannt, ich habe jetzt eine Festplatte, die zwar so halbwegs noch intakt ist, aber irgendwie schon so ein bisschen verkohlt ist?
Also die Preisgrößenordnung, ich stecke da nicht so tief drin in den Preisen, aber ich würde mal schätzen, dass so ein Durchschnittsfall vielleicht so 1500 Euro kostet oder so was in der Richtung. Und ich sag mal, die hauptsächlichen Kosten, aus meiner Sicht, ich hab da relativ tiefe Einblicke, wo denn überhaupt der Aufwand steckt. Die hauptsächlichen Kosten entstehen eigentlich dadurch, dass die Hersteller, wie soll ich sagen, dass die Hersteller keine Unterlagen über ihre Produkte rausrücken. Das heißt, man hat im Grunde genommen die meiste Zeit mit Reverse-Engineering zu tun.
Das heißt also zu verstehen, wie die Festplatten intern funktionieren, wie die Daten gespeichert sind und...
Genau. Und da diese, ich sag mal, die heutigen modernen Festplatten, bei denen ist ein riesiger Teil, ein riesiger Teil dessen, was sie können oder was sie notwendig brauchen, in Software realisiert. Das heißt also so eine Festplatte ist im Prinzip ein sehr leistungsfähiger Computer, ein sehr leistungsfähiger Signalverarbeitungsrechner. Und das Ganze geschieht ja auch dynamisch. Und da sind durchaus hochgradig mathematische Prozesse im Einsatz.
Das heißt also, das Magnetfeld wird quasi nicht mehr in elektronischen Bauteilen, in Bits und in Nullen und Einsen zusammen zurückgesetzt oder umgewandelt, sondern es passiert dann mit einer digitalen Signalverarbeitung.
Richtig. Also heute die typische moderne Festplatte hat zwischen dem Kopf und dem Computer in der Festplatte sozusagen nur noch typisch zwei Bauteile. Das eine ist ein Vorverstärker und das zweite ist ein sogenannter Equalizer. Und danach kommt sofort der AD-Wandler. Und von dort aus geht alles nur noch, sage ich jetzt mal, wird alles digital weiterverarbeitet. Das Kopfsignal wird abgetastet und diese Abtastwerte werden eben durch verschiedene Rechenstufen durchgeschoben. Also ich will jetzt nicht auf die einzelnen Rechenstufen eingehen, aber es sind eine Menge.
Okay, wenn mir das jetzt ein bisschen zu teuer ist oder meine Daten jetzt nicht ganz so wertvoll sind, dass es mir jetzt 1500 oder vielleicht 3000 Euro auch wert ist, was kann ich zumindest erst mal probieren? Also jetzt nenne ich, wenn es jetzt ein Feuerschaden ist oder mir die Festplatte, keine Ahnung, wenn ein Auto drübergefahren ist, dann ist wahrscheinlich Essig. Aber zumindest so Sachen mit ausgesehen mal Rm-Sternchen oder alle Daten jetzt nicht löschen, ja, nein, abbrechen, dann doch mal den falschen Knopf gedrückt hat. Was kann ich da als User, was ist so der beste Tipp erst mal?
Also für diese typischen Sachen gibt es natürlich allerlei Software da draußen und es gibt auch allerlei Informationen. Also wenn man da gerade bei offenen Systemen oder sowas, gibt es da ja alle Hand zu googeln zu dem Thema, würde ich sagen. Also ich würde zunächst mal mich da versuchen, schlau zu machen, was dann eigentlich mal ein Problem ist. Und im Falle von bestimmten Dateisystemen hat man ganz gute Chancen und im Falle von anderen hat man eben grottenhaft schlechte Chancen. Da wird man mit käuflicher Software, also jetzt so mit der typischen käuflichen Software nicht viel werden. Und bei anderen Dateisystemen sieht das ganz gut aus.
Was ist denn das Beste? Sofort Rechner ausschalten oder versuchen geordnet runterzufahren?
Na, es kommt darauf an, was ich hinterher damit tun will. Und es kommt darauf an, in welchem Stadium ich mich gerade befinde. Also ich würde sagen tendenziell, wenn ich die Absicht habe, damit hinterher einen professionellen Datenretter zu beauftragen, ist in der Tat das Beste, den Strom so schnell wie möglich von dem Rechner zu entfernen.
Und zum Schluss, oder Holger hat es noch?
Ich hab noch so Dau-Fragen irgendwie, zwei Stück. Wie lösche ich denn richtig, wenn ich mal wirklich löschen will?
Genau, das wäre jetzt auch meine Frage gewesen. Aber wir haben ja eine schöne Geschichte, ging so vor zwei, drei, vier Wochen in Berlin. Da hat der Polizei in Brandenburg, da sind ein paar Festplatten abhanden gekommen. Und es ist eine Sache, die passiert aber auch häufiger. Da gab es so eine Studie, wo die Leute einfach mal wahllos festplattengebauchte Festplatten auf Ebay ersteigert haben und haben sich dann über die Daten gefreut. Da waren wirklich interessante Sachen. So irgendwelche Lagepläne von der Polizei, Noteinsatzpläne, geheime Bankdaten, bis hin zu irgendwelchen Kinderpornosammlungen waren dann auf diesen Festplatten.
Na die sind ja, soweit ich das mitbekommen hab, nicht abhanden gekommen. Wir haben ja, meine Firma hat zu dem Thema ja auch eine Pressemitteilung von sich gegeben. Und die sind ja nicht abhanden gekommen, sondern ich meine, dass das so war, dass das durchaus berechnete Mitarbeiter der jeweiligen Behörde gewesen sind, die die da versteigert haben.
Ja, die haben die geklaut aus dem Schrank.
Ungerechtigte Mitarbeiter.
Aber wenn ich jetzt eine Festplatte oder einen Computer verkaufen will, sei es jetzt irgendwie an den Bekannten oder nicht Bekannten, und ich will jetzt nicht, dass meine Bankdaten und meine private Pornosammlung, Urlaubsbilder, E-Mails, was auch immer, da auf dieser Festplatte noch...
Deine Urlaubsbilder sind eine Pornosammlung?
Das ist ekelhaft.
Also einfach die Frage, wie lösche ich richtig als User oder als Consumer, ohne dass ich jetzt vielleicht bei euch vorbeigehe? Wie löscht ihr, wenn ihr was löscht?
Also wir bieten, oder jetzt die Firma, bei der ich arbeite, die bietet auch professionelle Löschprodukte an für jede Lebenslage. Also von der Löschsoftware bis hin zum Degausser, also so einem Gerät, das ein starkes Magnetfeld erzeugt.
Das heißt, ich zünde eine kleine Atombombe über meinem Computer und habe dann ein Magnetfeld, das alles löscht?
Ja, gut, ich würde dann vielleicht bei der Atombombenzündung vielleicht erstmal einen kleinen Metallring unter Strom setzen, damit du auch dann tatsächlich das Magnetfeld erzeugst. Denn die Atombombe alleine wird wahrscheinlich eher dazu führen, dass deine Festplatte verdampft.
Wir haben noch eine Spezialfrage. Also alle Nicht-Freaks können mal kurz weghören. Aber wir haben uns vorhin gefragt, es gibt ja diese Degausser, wo man mittlerweile, ich habe es auf der CeBIT gesehen, da stelle ich auch einen Laptop drauf. Dann macht er einmal kurz Knack und dann ist die Festplatte leer. Also ist das richtig meine Beobachtung gewesen oder war das eher ein... Aber es geht generell auch nur so bei Festplatten. Und der Harald meinte...
Mein Gott, ist auch kein so einfaches Thema. Wahrscheinlich wird die nicht mehr funktionieren, wenn das Feld stark genug ist.
Genau, das meinte ich.
Genau, das war nämlich die Sache, dass Harald meinte, dass auch mittlerweile die...
Lass doch Vick einfach mal erzählen, was das Problem ist.
Die Firmware...
Lass doch Vick einfach erst mal erzählen, warum sie nicht funktioniert.
Okay, erzähl, warum funktioniert das nicht?
Also das Problem daran ist, worüber im Moment auch trefflich, auch beim BSI und sonst wo und worüber trefflich und lange diskutiert wird und viele Messungen mit Rastakraftmikroskopen angestellt werden und ähnlichen Apparaten, ab welcher Magnetfeldstärke denn nun die Festplatte sauber ist. Dass sie nicht mehr funktioniert, kann nämlich viele Gründe haben. Das kann auch den Grund haben, was eine, beispielsweise eine Studie der Uni Regensburg gerade kürzlich festgestellt hat, dass die Nicht-Lestbarkeit der Festplatte auf der mechanischen Beschädigung derselben beruht und nicht unbedingt auf dem Verschwinden der Magnetisierung auf den Oberflächen. Und so ist das, also ich sag jetzt mal, wenn das Magnetfeld stark genug ist, ist die Festplatte leer. Aber wann das Magnetfeld stark genug ist, sag ich jetzt mal im Moment gerade heftig in Untersuchung.
Und zu stark sein darf es auch nicht?
Doch, natürlich. Also je stärker, desto besser. Und dann muss ich schon erheblichen technischen Auswand treiben. Also wenn ich sag ich jetzt mal über, sagen wir mal, 11.000, 12.000 Gauss Magnetfelder erzeugen will, dann muss ich da schon Supraleitende Magnete haben. Und dann wird das Ganze schon ziemlich sperren. Dann kann ich das nicht mehr mal in so ein Büro reinstellen.
Ein Gedanke, den ich noch hatte, das würde mich jetzt tatsächlich interessieren, ist es nicht so, dass bei modernen Festplatten teilweise die Software auch schon selber mit, oder dass sozusagen nur noch ein Bootloader in dem Flash oder was auch immer auf der Elektronik drauf ist und dass die restliche Software dann auch auf einer Platte, auf einer Spur ist, die sonst nicht ausgelesen werden kann?
Das ist korrekt.
Das würde damit dann auch weg sein.
Da kommen wir jetzt wieder zurück zu dieser Firmware-Thematik. Viele Leute haben sich ja ganz schlau gedacht, naja, Platte dreht nicht, wird wohl die Platine kaputt sein. Wechsel ich mal die Platine. Das kann bei heutigen Festplatten dazu führen, dass hinterher keine von beiden mehr geht. Der größte Teil der Plattenfirmen wäre in der Tat auf dem Medium gespeichert.
Das heißt also nach dem Degause ist die dann auch futsch?
Futsch und futsch, wie gesagt. Also wenn das Magnetfeld stark genug war, um die Oberfläche zu löschen, ja.
Ja, dann kann ich sie nicht mehr benutzen danach. Das ist eine Einmallöschung.
Ach so, das ist beim Degausen generell so. Ich kann sie nach dem Degausen nie mehr wieder verwenden.
Ach so, das war eine ürtimische Annahme. Ich hatte gedacht, die kann man danach noch wieder verwenden.
Nein, die sind danach zumindest, wenn das ein ehrlich funktionierender Degauser ist. Also wenn man sie hinterher noch verwenden kann, dann hat die Löschung überhaupt keine Wirkung gelassen. Dann kann man dann auch die Daten noch lesen.
Eine letzte Frage noch von mir. Jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit über Löschen geredet. Worauf würdest du was speichern, was du für die nächsten 50 Jahre aufheben willst?
Die Frage habe ich für mich auch noch nicht beantwortet. Ich denke mal, man wird nicht darum hinkommen, sie in den nächsten 50 Jahren weiterhin umzukopieren auf andere Medien. Vielleicht, ich denke mal, das meiste Vertrauen hätte ich im Moment zu flash speichern.
Das meiste Vertrauen zu flash speichern. Vielen Dank, Vic. Vic ist ein professioneller Datenretter gewesen mit dem medialen Telefon.
Oder auch Datenlöscher.
Wenn Fritz in Steglitz und Wilmersdorf, dann 102, 6.
Vier Minuten nach halb zwölf. Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht gibt's viele Wolken und stellenweise immer mal Regen. Das bei Tiefstwerten zwischen neun und drei Grad. Morgen wird's meist heiter, nur ganz selten soll's mal regnen. Die Höchsttemperaturen dann 14 bis 20 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldungen mit Matthias Kerkov.
Bundesregierungen und Gewerkschaften wollen die Weiterbildung arbeitsloser Jugendlicher verbessern. Dafür soll eine Expertengruppe aus Vertretern des Wirtschaftsministeriums, der Bundesagentur für Arbeit und der Gewerkschaften gebildet werden. DGB-Chef Sommer wies darauf hin, dass allein in Berlin zehnmal mehr Jugendliche ein Eurojobs machen als Ausbildungsmaßnahmen. Die Förderung der Ich-AGs wird bis Ende 2007 verlängert. Das beschloss das Kabinett in Berlin. Ursprünglich waren die Zuschüsse nur bis Ende 2005 geplant. Arbeitslose, die ihre Existenzgründung fördern lassen wollen, müssen allerdings mit einer strengeren Kontrolle der Erfolgsschancen rechnen. Der Großflughafen Schönefeld kann frühestens im Jahr 2011 und damit ein Jahr später als geplant eröffnet werden. Das teilte die Flughafen Schönefeld GmbH heute mit. Hintergrund ist der vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht verhängte vorläufige Baustopp. Der FC Chelsea muss um den Einzug in das Finale der Champions League bangen. Der designierte englische Fußballmeister musste sich im ersten Halbfinale gegen den Liga-Konkurrenten FC Liverpool mit einem 0 zu 0 begnügen. Der Verkehr auf Ritz für Berlin Brandenburg A10, südlicher Berliner Ring, Dreieck Potsdam Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Genshagen und Rangsdorf. Noch immer Gefahr nach einem Unfall mit mehreren Fahrzeugen.
Bitte Vorsicht. Danke Matthias, sechs Minuten und halb zwölf.
Direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof.
Oh, wie mir, wie mir, wie mir, wie mir.
Chaosradio 101 auf Fritz hier in Blumen ist, was ihr hört. Und um Datenspeicherung geht es, den ganzen Abend im Studio. Frank Harald unter die Knöpfe drückt Holger.
Ja, wir wollten jetzt mal ein bisschen was zu Backups erzählen. Nachdem wir jetzt darüber gesprochen haben, wie man denn am schnellsten und am besten und am dümmsten und am lustigsten Daten verliert und dass es auch professionelle Firmen gibt, die das für viel Geld im Zweifelsfall wieder herstellen können oder auch nicht, ist das Allerwichtigste eben die Datensicherung. Und da gibt es ja auch die aller unterschiedlichsten Verfahren und Möglichkeiten. Backups zu machen, da stellt sich natürlich erstmal die Frage, auf welche Art von Medium. Als Privatmensch hat man da nicht sehr viel Möglichkeit. Früher gab es die VHS-Tafes, das haben wir auch schon gehört. Mittlerweile kann man vielleicht irgendwie auf digitale Videobänder sichern. Das ist aber doch, wie soll ich sagen, etwas exotischere Variante. Und wie wir auch schon vorhin angesprochen hatten, sind echte Backup-Medien, also Bandlaufwerke, ob das jetzt DDS oder DLT oder LTO oder AIT oder wie auch immer die Hersteller die nennen mögen, sind komischerweise immer drei Buchstaben. Die sind einfach viel zu teuer. Also da kriege ich vernünftige Laufwerke nicht für unter knapp 900 oder 1000 Euro oder so. Und dann kosten die Medien auch dementsprechend. Das heißt, dass für jedes der Bänder, die ich da irgendwie reinschrieben will, das Laufwerk zahlt dann halt noch mal 150 Euro oder irgendwas. Das ist also nichts, was man sich irgendwie einfach mal so als Privatmensch leisten kann. Im professionellen Bereich wird das natürlich nicht desto sonst mit dieser Art Laufwerke gemacht. Im privaten Bereich habe ich eigentlich nur die Möglichkeit eben auch wieder Festplatten herzunehmen. Da gibt es extra eine USB Festplatten oder Firewire Festplatten oder in Wechselrahmen. Es gibt ja so Wechselrahmen für einen PC, wo man Festplatten ganz schnell austauschen kann. Und dann gibt es aber natürlich jetzt, unabhängig davon was für ein physisches Medium, ich nehme dann ganz andere Überlegungen. Wie will ich denn überhaupt einen Backup machen? Kopiere ich einfach irgendwie einen Platteninhalt oder meine Musiksammlung oder was auch immer, einfach mal rüber auf eine andere Platte, reicht mir das? Oder will ich das auch irgendwie, also will ich länger das zurückverfolgen können? Will ich nicht nur eine Kopie machen, also ich mache jetzt am Sonntag eine Kopie und das ist dann mein Backup und am nächsten Sonntag überschreibe ich das halt wieder mit den Daten von diesem Sonntag und dann stelle ich am Montag fest, oh letzten Mittwoch habe ich ja irgendwas. Tja, das war es dann. Das heißt, da gibt es dann Verfahren, wo ich dann mit sogenannten inkremenziellen oder differenziellen Sicherungen eben, was weiß ich mal, am ersten Vormonat mache ich ein vollständiges Backup und dann jede Woche darauf folgen, mache ich sicherlich dann nur die Änderungen ab diesem Monatsbeginn. Und dann kann ich sozusagen bis zum Monatsbeginn zurück immer noch wieder rekonstruieren.
Wobei ich mir vorher erstmal grundsätzlich Gedanken machen muss, was für ein Backup mache ich eigentlich? Mache ich einen Datensicherungs-Backup? Das heißt also gegen einen kurzfristigen Verlust der Daten, weil die Festplatte er braucht, oder mache ich ein langfristiges Archiv-Backup? Das heißt also, will ich die Sachen wirklich für mehrere Jahre möglicherweise oder für die Ewigkeit einlagern? Das ist also eine Entscheidung, die ich erstmal treffen muss.
Und dann hängt es auch häufig, also die Wahl des Mediums und so weiter, die hängt ja dann auch sehr davon ab, was sind das für Daten? Ja, das typische Beispiel, ob jetzt Foto oder MP3 oder Video oder was auch immer, Sammlung, also wo Daten einfach, ich fange da an zu sammeln und es werden immer mehr. Sowas ist ja eigentlich relativ leicht zu sichern, weil die alten Daten verändern sich ja nie. Es kommen immer nur neue dazu. Das heißt, für so ein System, da reicht es eigentlich auch, wenn ich ein intelligentes Programm habe, das mir immer wieder sagt, ach, jetzt sind wieder 4, 5 GB neue Daten da, jetzt brenne ich mal wieder eine DVD.
Also Stichwort MP3-Sammlung zum Beispiel.
Ja, beispielsweise. Ja, da kommt immer was dazu. Und immer, wenn sozusagen eine genügende Menge an neuen Daten dazugekommen ist, dann brenne ich wieder eine DVD oder so und dann habe ich mein komplettes Archiv in DVDs irgendwo liegen. Ich muss ja nie alles komplett kopieren, weil die alten Daten werden ja nicht mehr angefasst. Die verändern sich nicht. Also da sieht man schon, das ist eigentlich ein sehr vielschichtiges Problem, wo man, wo die Hauptarbeit eigentlich dahin hineingeht, überhaupt sich zu überlegen, wie organisiert man das? Wie welches Medium, wie sind die Daten, welche Zyklen und so weiter, ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen eine Denkaufgabe. Und danach entscheidet sich dann, welche Software, was für Medien, welche Technologie man einsetzt.
Welches der aktuellen Medien ist denn derzeit definitiv nicht für eine Langzeitarchivierung geeignet, deiner Meinung nach?
Na, was ist Langzeit?
Zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre. Na ja, bei zehn Jahren hat man mit Sicherheit bei Bändern schon häufig Schwierigkeiten. Richtig, also da hat man ja den Effekt dieser Durchmagnetisierung, weil das ja eine Spule ist, auf der das aufgewickelt ist. Und die jeweils darüber und darunter liegenden Schichten, die beeinflussen sich gegenseitig und magnetisieren sich gegenseitig. Das hört man auch bei alten Audiokassetten, wo man dann so ein Echo immer drauf hat, so ein bisschen Zeit verzögert. Das ist natürlich bei digitalen Informationen verheerend. Deswegen würde ich bei Bändern auch sagen, das ist mit Sicherheit nicht das Medium für zehn Jahre.
CDs, DVDs, also CD-R wieder, also beschreibbare CDs?
Ist auch wahrscheinlich mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Es kommt auf die Lagerung an. Das hatten wir vorhin auch schon mal angesprochen. Also eine gepresste CD hält sicherlich sehr lange. Die CD-Rs, also die beschreibbaren, die haben, also da ist es ja so, dass da so eine organische Schicht eingebracht ist in diesem Rolling. Bei DVD-Rs ist es das gleiche, was beschrieben wird. Die haben auch einen deutlich geringeren Reflexionsgrad als eine gepresste CD. Diese organischen Strukturen, wenn da Licht hinkommt, dann verändern sich die und dann wird dieser Reflexionsgrad noch geringer und irgendwann kann man die dann eben auch nicht mehr lesen. Also auch bei CDs, wenn ich sie nicht verwende, wenn ich sie tatsächlich einmal beschreibe und wenn ich sie dunkel und trocken lagere und nicht mechanisch belaste, dann denke ich schon, dass man nur zehn Jahre auf jeden Fall irgendwie damit abdecken kann und vielleicht nicht unbedingt die allerwilligsten Noname-Rollinge nimmt und auch keine Beschriftung vornimmt mit einem Stift, der irgendwelche... Genau, der sich dann durchätzt oder was auch immer. Das ist natürlich auch noch so ein Punkt, den man immer wieder beachten muss.
Und ein Mercy Book Who von mir.
Ich bin ein bisschen schuld, aber ich bin ein bisschen schuld. Ich bin ein bisschen schuld, aber ich bin ein bisschen schuld. Ich bin ein bisschen schuld, aber ich bin ein bisschen schuld. Wenn ich mich aber dagegen absichern möchte, dass ein Einbrecher in meine Wohnung oder in der Firma alles klaut oder gegen einen Brand oder was derartiges ist, Wasserschaden, was auch immer da sein mag, dann hilft das natürlich wenig. Dann muss ich die Backup-Medien natürlich auch irgendwo auslagern. Da gibt es Leute, die machen das in Wankschließfächern. Da gibt es Leute, die das einfach bei Bekannten oder Freunden unterbringen, aber einfach die physische Auslagerung der Daten, also einfach, dass man die woanders hin transportiert. Es gibt auch mittlerweile, je nachdem, was für Mengen das sind, Internetanbieter, wo man einfach die Daten übers Internet irgendwo anders hinweg sichert.
Wobei es also grundsätzlich natürlich auch ein Problem ist, wenn man die Sachen aus der Hand gibt. Wenn man die also selber von Hand in ein Bankschließfach bringt, ist es natürlich irgendwie der Idealfall, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass niemand anderes Zugriff hat zu dem Bankschließfach. Eine schöne Geschichte gibt es aus einem US-Atomwaffenlabor, wo sie mal Untersuchungen angestellt haben, wie die das eigentlich so halten mit der Datensicherheit und was damit passiert. Wir haben festgestellt, dass sie einfach die Backups in irgendwelche Briefumschläge tun und die per FedEx, also per Kurierdienst einfach irgendwo hinschicken. Und die wundern sich dann halt mal, naja, so am Ende des Jahres fehlen dann halt mal so ein paar Bänder. Und das ist dann halt schon ganz schön blöd bei den Daten, die da drauf sind. So was ist auch mal einer der Bank of America passiert. Die hatten eine kleine Anzahl von Backup-Bändern verloren, die sind abgängig, also weg. Und ja, da waren dann halt irgendwie Millionen Kundendaten drauf. Und das ist natürlich ganz schön blöd bei so einen Backups. Und da gibt es ja eine Strategie, die zu verschlüsseln. Was natürlich auch nicht so ganz ohne ist, weil ich muss dann auch sehen, dass ich den Schlüssel zum Entschlüsseln auch wieder tatsächlich gut aufbewahre. Und ich muss sehen, dass es zum einen natürlich auch sehr belastend ist für die Hardware. Das heißt, es dauert unter Umständen sehr lange, die Datenende abzulegen. Und ich brauche natürlich auch, wenn ich jetzt eine spezielle Software verwendet habe, eine, die das dann auch wieder entschlüsseln kann. Und ich sollte auch darauf aufpassen, dass derjenige, das Systemadministrator, der das Kennwort hat, um den Schlüssel zu entschlüsseln oder das Wissen darüber, wie die Daten zu entschlüsseln sind, nicht plötzlich bei einem Autounfall stirbt oder einen Herzinfarkt. So was ist auch schon mal vorgekommen. Ich glaube, einer Bibliothek oder einem Archiv in, ich glaube, Norwegen war es, und in Skandinavien. Und die haben dann per Zeitung und Radioaufruf nach einem Hacker gesucht, der denen dann helfen konnte, diese Daten irgendwie zu entschlüsseln.
Hat es funktioniert?
Es hat funktioniert, es hat jemand geschafft.
Immerhin hat sich jemanden herzgerechnet. Ich habe eben einen kurzen Zwischenruf. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber wann immer Axel anruft, ist irgendwas.
Ja, genau dazu zum Problem sichern auf Festplatten. Man sollte sich dabei im Hinterkopf aber behalten, dass die Industrie, die heutzutage Festplatten herstellt, nur noch Standzeiten von Daten auf Platten ohne überschreiben, ganz wichtig, ohne überschreiben, von drei bis fünf Jahren gibt. Die Strukturen auf den Platten sind mittlerweile so winzig klein, dass die Branche Molekular Bewegung und ähnliche nette Effekte, die Platten dazu bringen, dass sie innerhalb der Schreckenkurzerzeit ihre Daten wieder verlieren. Waren zu Beginn, wie wir vorhin erzählt haben, als die Festplatten erfunden worden sind, noch Standzeiten von 50 Jahren geplant, ist man heute bei zwischen drei und fünf Jahren. Das ist so richtig, dass Dauermedium auch nicht ist, es sei denn man schreibt also in regelmäßigen Abständen die Platte neu.
Ja, das ist richtig, dass das erwähnt wird. Das ist auch bekannt, das ist generell ein Problem der Miniaturisierung. Also man hat das gleiche bei Arbeitsspeichern eigentlich auch. Es ist ein bisschen anders gelagert das Problem, weil die Strukturen jetzt in einem Arbeitsspeicher von Computern auch so fein werden mittlerweile. Und dadurch nur noch so wenig Ladung, also bei den Arbeitsspeichern ist es elektrische Ladung, bei den magnetischen Datenträgern ist es eben diese Magnetisierung. Und es ist noch so wenig Ladung, die die Unterschied zwischen 1 und 0 letztendlich ausdrückt, dass die kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung da ausreicht, da öfter mal ein Bit zu kippen. Genau. Und ja, dann sind die Daten halt auch entsprechend corrupted.
Genau, das Nette bei der Platte, wie groß ist ein Bit? Ungefähr ein Bit ist ungefähr 200 Nanometer lang und 50 Nanometer breit. Wobei ein Nanometer ein Milliardsvolteil eines Millimeters ist sehr erschreckend.
Ich hab grad...
Auf ein menschliches Haar passen in der Breite ungefähr 10.000 Bit. Das ist schon ein bisschen erschreckend. Und diese Größe wird also ungefähr eine Milliarde Mal pro Sekunde geschrieben, wenn so eine Platte beschrieben wird.
Das ist doch scheiße. Ich meine, das kann doch nur schiefgehen.
Ja, natürlich ist es erschreckend, dass es immer noch funktioniert. Wenn man sich jetzt noch im Hinterkopf fällt, dass so eine Scheibe, die in so einer Festplatte rotiert, innerhalb von einer Minute fertig ist in der Produktion. Also abgesehen von dem Glaspräger, der dauert länger. Aber die eigentliche Beschichtung und Fertigstellung der Scheibe dauert ungefähr eine Minute. Ist das schon relativ erschreckend, dass das immer noch so gut geht.
Ich kauf mir einen Plattenspieler.
Ich bin mittlerweile... Also ich hab da so eine Statistik mir angeguckt in der Vorbereitung zur Sendung, wo es darum ging, wie sich denn die Speicherdichte eben immer weiter erhöht hat. Und dachte mir so, ach, sieht ja ganz beeindruckend aus. Und bis ich dann gesehen hab, oh, die Skala ist ja logarithmisch. Das heißt noch beeindruckender.
Das ist fast eine Gerade, aber die Skala ist leider logarithmisch.
Ja, und wo wir gegenwärtig so 2003, 2004 war das angekommen, das war also ein Terabyte pro Quadratfuß Oberfläche. Ja, genau. Also Quadratfuß sind irgendwie so 30 mal 30 Zentimeter oder so.
Ja, und wie gesagt, erschreckend ist dann natürlich auch die Magnetfelder, mit denen dann auf die Platte drauf losgegangen wird. Ja, wird man eigentlich auch relativ blass, weil irgendwie ein Tesla ist. Da wird zurzeit eine relativ interessante Größe, also eine relativ aktuelle Größe.
Kann man das irgendwie greifbar?
Ja, ein Tesla ist Faktor 100.000 zum Erdmagnetfeld ungefähr. Das ist auch nicht so richtig greifbar, gebe ich zu. Stell dir was anderes vor. Stell dir einen großen Magneten vor, der einen Tesla hat. Innen in deinem Wohnzimmer. Du gehst zur Zimmertür rein, lässt deinen Schlüsselbund los. Der fliegt definitiv dahin.
Das ist ziemlich magnetisch.
Gut, aber wie gesagt Festplatten sind auch nicht so die Dauerlösung. Dann muss ich doch eher auf DRT-Bänder oder so ausweichen, weil es natürlich für einen Heim bedarf.
Na, wir hatten ja auch nicht, vielleicht ist es jetzt vorher falsch rübergekommen, wir hatten ja nicht propagiert, dass Festplatten die Lösung für Dauerbackups wären. Das hatten wir nicht ausgesagt.
Das ist was für ein Image, wo man sagt, okay in einem halben Jahr stürzt irgendwann mal mein System ab und ich muss es wieder herstellen, das mag gut funktionieren.
Ja, oder aber wenn ich tatsächlich einfach, also jetzt der Standard Heimanwender, ich mach halt irgendwie einmal im Monat oder einmal die Woche, kopiere ich einfach.
Dann überschreibe ich es ja immer. Dann ist ja nicht die Frage. Also das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass die Platte relativ mühelos 20 Jahre leben kann. Aber die Daten selber unüberschrieben. Darum geht es nicht, dass das eventuell unbekannt wird.
Und dann hat nochmal der Jens aus Ilmenau angerufen.
Ja, so als nette Story, vielleicht sicherlich nicht für den Heimanwender irgendwie, aber haben sich, ich weiß nicht, habe ich schon mal gehört, Leute auch Gedanken gemacht, wieso das Wissen von der Welt oder so verewigt werden kann, dass es auch ein bisschen länger hält als in ein paar hundert Jahren. Und da haben sie sich das Prinzip des Steinmeißelns vorgenommen und haben das auf Kreisrunde aus bestimmten Metall, solche Scheiben übertragen. Und haben angefangen in einer Schriftgröße darauf zu grafieren.
Das Ganze in eine Glaskugel eingebaut.
Ich hab gehört, dass sie das so grafiert haben, dass man es in den Augen lesen kann, wo sie kurz beschreiben, wie das halt darauf geht.
Das ist folgendermaßen, sie haben eine Scheibe, ungefähr CD-Größe, und haben in sieben verschiedenen Sprachen, also das ist nur ein Prototypen, den sie da gemacht haben, in sieben verschiedenen Sprachen, ich glaube, weiß ich nicht, die Offenbarung des Johannes oder sowas, genommen, haben die auf diese Scheibe geprägt, also tatsächlich in Schriftform. Und haben praktisch links angefangen, also haben die die Schriftgröße verjüngt sich immer weiter nach rechts, sodass du eigentlich schon alleine dadurch, dass du dir das anguckst, gezwungen bist, von links nach rechts zu lesen und von außen nach innen auf dieser Scheibe. Und du kommst danach wirklich nur noch, die sind dann nachher auf Atomebene, wo sie den Text geschrieben haben, und du kommst hinterher dann tatsächlich nur noch mit dem Elektronenmikroskop an die letzten Worte, die sich dann im Zentrum der Scheibe ins Zentrum der Scheibe reingeschrieben haben. Und die Idee ist eben, was zu schaffen, was ähnlich lange überdauert, wie eine Steintafel, die früher 2000 oder 4000 Jahren gemeißelt wurde, und gleichzeitig aber auch die Funktion eines Rosettasteins hat. Also der Rosettastein, für die, die es nicht wissen, ist ein Stein, der ist gefunden worden in Rosetta, in einer Stadt. Darauf waren Hieroglyphen, gleichzeitig Keilschrift, glaube ich, und griechische Schrift. Und anhand dieses Steins sind die Hieroglyphen entziffert worden, weil in der griechischen Schrift, die man lesen konnte, stand da drauf. Dieser Text ist in drei Sprachen identisch. Das ist der Stein von Rosetta. Diese Scheibe, die haben sie eingebacken praktisch oder gelegt zwischen zwei Glashalbkugeln, womit sie das richtig dicht verschlossen haben und da noch mal ein Stahlring drum, weil sie sich gesagt haben, wir wollen das Ding so attraktiv machen, dass es niemand kaputt macht und dass selbst in 5000 oder 10.000 Jahren jemand noch irgendwie darüber stolpert. Also dass das auffällig findet, dass da ein wirklich völlig eine glaskugel ist, völlig rund und da irgendwas drin ist. Danke Jens. Hier ist Chaosradio 101. Unser CD ist gerade abgelaufen. Sollen wir mal hier MIA spielen, was ich eben vorgespielt hab? Irgendwie was vergleichsweise Neues, alle kennen es, nur wir nicht. MIA aus London. Chaosradio 101. Datenspeicherung, Datenverlust und Archivierung geht's.
Genau, wir wollen uns jetzt ein bisschen mehr der Archivierung widmen. Das heißt also der langfristigen Aufbewahrung und Konservierung von Daten. Das ist hauptsächlich anzutreffen in Museen, in Bibliotheken. Aber auch wenn ich so meine, kommen wir wieder zu den Urlaubsvideos zurück, zu meinen Urlaubsvideos sichern will, meine selbst gedrehten Filme, Musik, die ich vielleicht mal selbst gemacht hab, aber auch schon allein meine Briefe, die ich vielleicht nicht auf Papier ausgedruckt hab oder irgendwelche Sachen, die ich mal geschrieben hab, sei es irgendwie mal irgendwelche Schularbeiten, irgendwelche Diplomarbeiten oder was auch immer, was ich mal geschrieben hab. Und im Bereich Audio Video haben wir da die Probleme, in welchem Format speichern wir das eigentlich ab. Also das ist da ganz besonders wichtig. Das heißt also, werden die Sachen komprimiert, in welcher Größe speichern wir sie ab, in welcher Qualität, wie viel Informationen gehen dabei möglicherweise verloren. Also das ist vielleicht im Heimbedarf, ist das nicht so dramatisch, aber zum Beispiel bei Fernsehanstalten, bei Radiostationen ist ja interessant, in welcher Qualität will ich mir das eigentlich leisten, die Daten aufzuheben? Will ich ja so eine möglichst CD-Qualität aufheben oder will ich sie irgendwie komprimieren? Bei CDs brauche ich dann tatsächlich wirklich eine CD für die Daten, wenn ich sie unkomprimiert ablegen will oder will ich sie zum Beispiel als MP3 ablegen, dann passen immerhin schon 10-fache, 12-fache ungefähr auf so eine CD rauf. Das Gleiche muss ich mir überlegen bei Videos, will ich die jetzt in großen Videokassetten ablegen, wo die Sachen unkomprimiert, das heißt, in voller Größe vorhanden sind, oder will ich die klein komprimieren, dass sie irgendwie auf eine CD rauf passen, auf eine DVD runter komprimieren. Das ist ja schon eine relativ starke Kompression. Ich muss mir bei Bildmaterial überlegen, wenn ich hier zum Beispiel irgendwelche alten Bücher in Büchereien einscane, die für die Archivierung oder die auch im Internet öffentlich machen will, in welcher Qualität, in welchem Formaten mache ich das? Bei Büchern kommt zusätzlich noch das Problem rein. Jaja Holger, so schnell geht das.
Wie will ich die Cola archivieren?
Ich archiviere hier gerade mal einen Schluck Cola.
Bei Büchereien ist das Problem, wie katalogisiere ich die Sachen, wie indiziere ich sie? Wie mache ich sie durchsuchbar? Wenn ich jetzt ein Buch einscanne, habe ich erst mal nur ein Grafikbild. Ich kann also nicht nach einem Volltext suchen. Gerade bei alten Schriften ist es so, die kann ich nicht einfach durch eine OCR, durch eine Schrifterkennung durchjagen. Dann kommt hinten der Text raus, sondern ich muss mich wirklich manuell ransetzen. Das abtippt mir in der Regel. Es gibt zwar mittlerweile ein paar Projekte, die auch versuchen, altertümliche Schriften automatisch zu erkennen, aber das ist natürlich nicht ganz so einfach wie bei einer Standard-Schreibmaschinenschrift. Und da gibt es also jede Menge Archivprojekte. Und es gibt auch ziemlich viele Leute, die sich mittlerweile damit beschäftigen. Und eben natürlich auch mit der Frage, wie viel Informationen wollen wir uns leisten, aufzuheben und wie viel können wir riskieren, zu verlieren? Also, das Problem ist, wenn ich jetzt ein Buch einscanne und ich nehme jetzt nur noch den Text auf, das heißt also den abgetippten, also nicht das eingescannte Bild, sondern ich hebe jetzt nur den Text auf, dann gehen natürlich die ganzen Informationen über den Satz, das heißt über die Schaffenheit des Papiers, über bestimmte grafische Zeichen gehen dabei verloren. Oder wenn ich jetzt nur so ein Bild einscanne, zum Beispiel ich entscheide mich, ich will es nur in Graustufen einscannen, um vielleicht Speicherplatz zu sparen, dann gehen die glückliche Farbinformation verloren. Also möglicherweise irgendwelche Nuancen, die es damals gab. Das gleiche ist bei Video. Möglicherweise irgendwelche Sachen werden unscharf, die werden durch die Auflösung von den Sachen nicht mehr zu erkennen. Ich habe an manchen Stellen möglicherweise Verluste, auch bei Audio das gleiche. Wenn ich die Sachen komprimiere, dann gibt es halt irgendwelche Geräusche, die später nicht mehr da sind. Das heißt also, wie exakt will ich die Sachen eigentlich konservieren, archivieren und auch für die Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen. Und das sind so Sachen, die ich bei der Langzeitarchivierung dann auch genau abschätzen muss und die natürlich dann auch durch einen Kostenrahmen oder durch das Budget vorgegeben werden. Und das ist halt ziemlich ärgerlich, weil bei manchen Archivierungsprojekten gehen so eine Sachen dann verloren oder werden nicht berücksichtigt oder gehen einfach aus Geldmangel. Werden dann Sachen in ziemlich großem Aufwand eingescannt. Aber eine Forschergeneration später sagt aber, jetzt bräuchten wir aber Informationen aus den Daten, die dabei verloren gegangen sind. Einfach weil man sich damals noch keine Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, dass sie vielleicht noch gebraucht werden könnten. Ja. Genau, schönes Beispiel für so ein Problem, wo Daten verloren gehen, ist, wenn ich dann ein altes Gemälde abfotografiere und zu sagen, okay, ich nehme eine wahnsinnig hohe Auflösung, so und so viel 1000 dpi und alles bestens perfekt ausgeleuchtet, ich fotografiere es ab. Verschiedene Ansichten und hier und da. Und stelle dann hinterher fest zum Beispiel, dass das Gemälde aus mehreren Schichten besteht, die ich nur sehen kann, wenn ich das Gemälde oder Röntgen, wenn ich halt so ein Röntgenbild von einem Gemälde mache und dadurch sehe, dass in den Schichten unter der ersten Farbe auch noch andere Sachen sind, aber dann sind die durch ein Foto verloren gegangen. Und sowas Ähnliches kann natürlich auch bei Texten jetzt nicht das gleiche, aber in ähnlichen Sachen kann es sein, dass ich durch das Scannen einfach bewusste Informationen wie zum Beispiel Konturen, also verschiedene, also dreidimensionale Geschichten, denn dadurch verliere, die hinterher für Forscher möglicherweise wichtig sind. Und das sind so Sachen, da kann ich jetzt, da kann man den Leuten auch, die sowas denn in Anführungszeichen verbockt haben, natürlich auch keinen Vorwurf machen, weil die konnten ja nicht vorhersehen, dass es diesen Bedarf, diesen Forschungsbedarf möglicherweise mal besteht. Das ist also so ein großes Problem bei der Archivierung. Wie viel kann ich jetzt schon abschätzen, was ich später mal brauche davon?
Das sieht man ja eigentlich, also geht in die gleiche Problematik hinein, wie man es auch in der Archäologie hat, wo man sagt, ja, irgendwelche Gräber oder was auch immer geöffnet wurde von den ersten Archäologen vor hunderten von Jahren. Die hatten ja noch keine, was weiß ich, Röntgengeräte, Rastellos, Elektronen, Mikroskope, was es nicht alles für tolle Technologien mittlerweile gibt. Und das, was damals sozusagen verloren gegangen ist, dadurch, dass sie diese Technologie nicht hatten, das hat man heute eben auch nicht. Und das ist bei der Archivierung dann natürlich ähnlich. Und ja, auch was bei der Archivierung, was mir bei Archivierung von Medien auch noch einfällt, vor allem ist auch, dass die Ausgangsqualität natürlich auch immer schon sehr schlecht ist. Also wenn ich jetzt alte schwarz-weiß Videoaufnahmen, zum Beispiel irgendwie historische Dokumente aus dem Dritten Reich oder was auch immer, wenn ich die jetzt heute digitalisiere, dann sind die analogen Ausgangsmaterialien ja schon total überaltert und verrauscht und mit allen möglichen Defekten im Bild. Und diese ganzen Defekte machen ja dann auch die Bemühungen von modernen Komplosionsverfahren zu nicht. Also ich kann, wenn ich jetzt ein verrauschtes Ausgangsmaterial hab, dann kann ich das ganz schlecht nur komprimieren, jetzt also MPEG oder was auch immer für digitale Komplosionsverfahren, für Video. Hingegen hab ich ein sauberes Ausgangsbild, das jetzt gerade letztes Jahr aufgenommen wurde, dann funktioniert das auch viel besser. Also da gibt es auch noch dann Schwierigkeiten aus der Ecke. Und ein ganz anderer Bereich, den man bei der Archivierung auch noch kennt, ist natürlich nicht nur die Archivierung, weil man jetzt als Museum oder als irgendeine Art öffentliche Institution, die die Wissen aufrechterhalten will oder Dokumente archivieren will. Es gibt ja auch rechtliche Anforderungen, wann bestimmte Dinge zu archivieren sind. Also als Beispiel sei da zum Beispiel genannt, dass Banken Auflagen haben, bestimmte Unterlagen entsprechend lange vorzuhalten. Also es gibt da unterschiedliche Haltezeiten. Ich hab das im Detail nicht mehr im Kopf, ich muss mich da mal damit beschäftigen, aber eins ist mir im Kopf geblieben, dass es gibt tatsächlich Unterlagen, die Banken unendlich lange aufbewahren müssen. Ja, wie sind sie archivieren müssen. Das kann sich natürlich auch nur ein Land leisten, das nur 50 Jahre alt ist. 20 Jahre, 30 Jahre ist ja alles noch verständlich, aber beliebig lang muss das aufbewahrt werden, das ist natürlich schon eine typisch juristische Definition. Das sind meines Wissens nach Kontoeröffnungsunterlagen. Wenn ich ein Konto irgendwo eröffne, dann muss dieses Dokument, mit dem das Konto eröffnet wurde, das muss dann beliebig lang vorgehalten werden. Zumindest bis vor 5, 6 Jahren war das so, dass man tatsächlich diese ganze Archivierung auch aus rechtlichen Gründen heraus alles noch analog, also auf Mikrofilm, Mikrofisch und dergleichen vornehmen musste. Man konnte das schon zusätzlich auch noch digital archivieren, aber die rechtliche Grundlage dafür, dass diese digitale Fotokopie, sozusagen das gescannte Dokument, dann auch vor Gericht, bei viel Geld geht es dann ja auch häufig um Gerichtsverfahren oder Steuerhinterziehung, was auch immer, dass das dann standhält, da hat tatsächlich nur das analoge damals, ich weiß nicht, was es mittlerweile ist, könnte sich geändert haben. Und da entstehen natürlich auch ganz schöne Datenberge in solchen Archivierungsabteilungen.
Vielleicht weiß es ja jemand, also weiß von euch jemand, wie Banken mittlerweile die Dinge archivieren, die für sehr lange archiviert werden müssen, dann rufen wir uns an 0331 70 97 110. Nagen Nagen. Okay, wir streiten uns gerade ein wenig. Also nur ein wenig, weil Frank sagt.
Ich habe meine MP3s, sortiere ich von Hand. Das heißt also nicht alphabetisch, sondern ich habe jetzt so fünf, sechs Oberkategorien, wo ich die quasi thematisch einordne. Was den Vorteil hat, dass ich da noch irgendwie, wenn ich es von Hand mache, dann habe ich einen Überblick. Das heißt, du kannst mir einen Interpreten sagen und ich kann dir sagen, oder eine Band, ich kann dir sagen, ob ich die habe und zum anderen, in welcher Unterkategorie die bei mir drin ist.
Ja gut, ob ich eine Band oder einen Interpreten habe, kann ich dir auch sagen und ich sortiere die nicht von Hand, sondern das macht bei mir iTunes und wenn ich da was von ihnen haben will, dann hab ich oben rechts, in iTunes ist so ein kleines Fensterchen, da tippe ich dann zum Beispiel ein Kraftwerk und dann spuckt das Ding alles aus, was ich von Kraftwerk habe.
Dann musst du aber tatsächlich auch iTunes immer benutzen. Aber es ist halt blöd, wenn du zum Beispiel dann irgendwie was zusammenstellen willst oder mal eben jemand noch eine CD, eine Audio-CD brennen willst oder zum Beispiel jetzt die Musik für hier oder so.
Also iTunes aber auch.
Ja, aber es ist halt wieder so ein Vendor-Login, zum Beispiel könnte man sagen, und auch so eine Kompatibilitätsfrage. Wie lange wird es iTunes geben? Gibt es das in 20 Jahren noch?
Na ja gut, iTunes legt ja trotzdem ein Dateisystem an, durch das ich mich dann arbeiten kann im Zweifelsfall.
Das ist denn alphabetisch geordnet?
Das ist alphabetisch nach Künstler, es sei denn du sagst, es ist eine Compilation. Also wenn du ein Häkchen setzt, wenn du es rippst und setzt, ein Häkchen, sagst du, dieses Ding ist Teil einer Compilation, dann legt das unter Compilation und dann Künstlernamen ab.
Aber nicht nach dem Unterordner der Compilation sozusagen, sondern dann nimmt er die Compilations auseinander oder wie funktioniert das?
Nee, du hast dann ein Folder, der heißt Compilations und da drin dann Kraftwerk, falls das eine Kraftwerk-Compilation ist.
Ah, verstehe. Und wenn es jetzt aber eine komplett gemischte Compilations ist, also ein Ensembler sozusagen?
Dann legt das unter Künstlernamen ab. Dann legt das unter Künstler ab.
Das heißt, er nimmt die denn auseinander.
Er nimmt die auseinander, sei denn du sagst... Das ist ja immer bekloppt. Nein, wieso? Das ist doch dann... wieso? Wenn du das Häkchen setzt an Compilation, macht das nicht und sonst macht das.
Da hinterlegt er aber schon die ganze Compilation ab, als Stück, also als Verzeichnis.
Ich glaub, ich muss jetzt hier mal intervenieren.
Nein, Moment mal. Nee, der Frank will das gerade nicht verstehen, das find ich sehr lustig. Also ich hab eine CD, ein Sampler, eine Compilation, wie auch immer du es nennen willst. So und ich habe die Wahl, das entweder auseinander gerissen, unter Künstlernamen, unter den Namen der jeweiligen Künstler, oder aber en bloc als Compilation. Ah, okay.
Dann bleibt sie dann da zusammen in dem Fall.
Dann bleibt sie da zusammen und die hat ja dann auch irgendeinen Namen. Also es ist ja, ja.
Verstehe.
Aber warum sollte ich denn hindisch meine MP3 sortieren?
Weil du zum Beispiel so viel Musik irgendwo herumliegen hast, die du von so vielen CD's mal gerippt hast, die du dir alle irgendwann mal gekauft hast, dass du, und da bist du in einer bestimmten Stimmung. Und dann möchtest du eine bestimmte Musik hören, aber du hast jetzt nicht im Kopf dieser Künstler oder dieses Album oder so. Dann möchtest du einfach aus dieser Ecke oder was irgendwie so in die Richtung geht hören. Und dann hilft dir das halt mit der alphabetischen Ablage relativ wenig. Also eigentlich willst du ein System haben, das mp3s ablegt und wo dann mehr mehrere Indizes oder mehrere Zugriffsmöglichkeiten da war fast.
Die hab ich doch in iTunes auch.
Na, da hast du vielleicht noch das Genre, das im mp3 Tag steht.
Ja, das ist ja nichts.
Da gibt's vielleicht 10 oder 15 oder so.
Na, kann ich da reinschreiben, weil ich will.
Ja gut, dann...
Dann musst du dir aber auch wieder alle von Hand jede Datei einzeln anpassen, oder? Wie machten ihr das eigentlich? Also gebt uns mal Tipps. Also helft uns jetzt hier mal, wie sortiert ihr eigentlich eure mp3s?
0331 70 97 110. Wie sortiert ihr denn eure mp3s? Tragt ihr die per Hand in den Keller und steckt sie dann in die Festplatte? Oder wie macht ihr das?
Ausdrucken und den Dreifacherkopie ablegen.
Genau, einfach die Diskette nehmen und abheften.
0331 70 97 110. Wie sortiert ihr eure mp3s? Fragen wir doch einfach mal Hendrik aus Dresden. Er hat zwar aus einem anderen Grund angerufen, aber das war ja gar nicht das Thema. Hallo Hendrik.
Hallo.
Wie sortierst du denn deine mp3s?
Um kurz mal auf mp3s zurückzukommen, da wäre 3Tech jetzt so ein Ding, wo man halt die mp3s einfach mal verteckt, den verschiedenen Sachen zuweisen, wie z.B. Album, Name, Aufnahmedatum, Künstlername und dann kann man das Ganze in der Winnet Media Library auch noch raten, das heißt, man vergibt halt für seine Lieblingsstücke ein relativ hohes Rating und für weniger beliebte Stücke ein niedriges Rating und dann kommt man relativ schnell mit Winnet durch seine Musikstücke.
Das klingt mir so nach so einer Charts-Lösung.
Nee, eigentlich weniger. Ich bin nicht so der Charts-Fan.
Und diese Information, dieses Rating, wie wird die abgelegt? Weißt du das, wo die gespart wird?
Ich glaube, das macht Winem selbst. Also ich müsste da jetzt auch nachgucken. Ich hab das auch noch nicht so exklusiv genutzt. Keine Ahnung, aber ich manage da mit 100 Gigs an MP3 und es ist ausreichend. Ich bin mein MP3. Ich bin auch derjenige, der sich die Künstler noch merkt.
Also du hast auch noch den Überblick bei deinen 100 Gigs.
Über 100 Gigs MP3, da behält man noch den Überblick.
Danke, Hendrik. Du hattest aber noch was anderes.
Ich hatte eigentlich noch was anderes zum Thema hier, wenn man mehr oder weniger schlecht positioniert, seine Position vergrößert oder verkleinert und sich halt nur mit Windows auskennt, gibt es da entsprechende Tools, um die Daten zu retten. Falls dabei was schief geht. Da wäre zu nennen GetDataBag, das gibt es für FAT32 und für NTFS. Und damit habe ich ganz gute Ergebnisse erzielt.
Das ist, wenn du was in Dateien gelöscht hast oder wenn du was aus der Sendformatität hast?
Das kannst du benutzen, wenn du Dateien gelöscht hast. Also das findet alles an Daten aus, was du so an deiner Partition Table findest, in der File Allocation Table. Und kannst du relativ viel retten, solange es Text ist. Kannst du aus dem Text dann halt noch was rauslesen, sofern da was auffindbar ist. Wenn es mp3s sind, da hast du dann halt mal einen Stocken drin. Wenn du jetzt wie gesagt bloß deine Partition zahlen hast, deine Partitions-Tabelle, dann ist es kein Problem, damit komplette Partitionen wieder herzustellen. Wichtig ist es halt, dass man die Festplatte nur lesend einbindet, beziehungsweise halt nicht schreibend drauf zugreift, wenn man die Daten noch retten will. Und dann kann man die Daten, sofern man auch eine zweite Festplatte hat, die leer ist, dann mal eben fix extrahieren. Ist eigentlich eine ganz kleine Sache. Kann ich hier den Daueralt empfehlen.
Okay, ja, ist vielleicht ein ganz guter Punkt, dass wir noch mal auch ein bisschen so auf das Löschen und was passiert da eigentlich und so dieses, die Art und Weise, ja, was, ja...
Löschen ist ein, also es gibt ja unter professionellen Datenschützern einmal den Begriff Daten löschen, dann einmal den Begriff unwiederbringlich zerstören und was sozusagen auch gern genommen wird, anstatt zu löschen heißt, als gelöscht markieren. Das ist also gern, wenn es darum geht, so um Kundendaten, Banken und Personen, also personenbezogene Daten. Die Daten werden gelöscht, was heißt denn gelöscht? Naja, sie werden als gelöscht markiert. Das heißt, sie sind zwar vermerkt, als die sind nicht mehr vorhanden, aber natürlich auch da. Und im Prinzip, sowas ähnliches passiert eigentlich auch bei einer Festplatte, wenn ich die Daten mit einem löschen, also wenn ich sie in Papierkorb, vielleicht im Papierkorb leere, dann sind aus Sicht der Festplatte die Daten dann einfach nur als gelöscht markiert. Also sprich, die Verweise darauf auf die Daten sind weg. Aber die Daten sind natürlich trotzdem noch auf dem Datenträger, so lange bis sie überschrieben werden. Das heißt, da wird einfach ein Speicherbereich freigegeben auf der Festplatte. Die Daten selbst, der Text oder die Musik, sind aber an sich im Wesentlichen noch vorhanden.
Ja, das ist also eines der größten Probleme, wenn es um dieses echte Löschen geht. Das andere, was ja auch schon mehrfach in der Sendung angesprochen wurde, sind die Partitionstabellen oder das überhaupt Festplatten partitioniert. Und hier ist es eben so, dass da am Anfang von der Festplatte so eine kleine Tabelle steht, in der die Aufteilung in die Partitionen drin steht. Wenn diese Tabelle verloren geht, dann weiß ich sozusagen nur nicht mehr an welcher Stelle auf der Festplatte so eine Partition beginnt und wo sie endet. Das ist aber jetzt eigentlich kein Problem, das wieder herauszufinden. Das kann man auch durch Software eben wieder herausfinden, indem man die ganze Festplatte absucht und nach typischen Signaturen sucht, die zum Ausdruck bringen, dass jetzt hier zum Beispiel so ein FAT32 oder was auch immer für ein Dateisystem anfängt oder eben aufhört. Das kann man also an der Stelle sicherlich leicht wiederherstellen. Und überhaupt als Tipps vielleicht noch zum Wie kann ich Daten später noch wiederherstellen. Ganz schlecht ist es überhaupt, nachdem man einen Datenverlust hatte, solche Dinge wie Scandisk oder Defragmentierung oder was auch immer oder irgendwelche solchen Programme aufzurufen. Häufig macht man damit das Problem nämlich nur noch schlimmer. Wenn man wirklich, angenommen ich hab was gelöscht, was echt essentiell ist und wo ich unbedingt wieder rankommen möchte und ich auch bereit bin, viel Aufwand hineinzustecken, dann ist es in jedem Fall sinnvoll sofort am besten Stecker raus, was auch immer, das System abschalten und dann die Festplatte in ein anderes System einzubauen. Ich bute dann den zweiten Rechner einfach hoch, da baue ich die Festplatte mit den gelöschten Daten ein und dann kann ich auf die Festplatte, ohne dass ich Daten von ihr benutze, ohne dass da das Betriebssystem zum Beispiel drauf wäre, kann ich da dann eben noch arbeiten damit. Und auf keinen Fall Filesystem check oder Scan-Disc oder sonst irgendwas aufrufen, weil da macht man sich dann häufig die Problemen noch deutlich schlimmer.
Wir waren noch dabei zu fragen, wie die Höhenden ihre MP3s organisieren.
Danke erstmal.
Um Frank endgültig davon zu überzeugen, dass iTunes durchaus eine wirklich gute Lösung ist. Wer wartet denn am längsten? Die Sabine. Hallo Sabine. Hallo. Wie sortierst du deine MP3s?
Also ich hab das mit Hand gemacht.
Mit Hand?
Genau.
Und alphabetisch, oder?
Ich wollte immer was in den Tapeten für Musik machen und dann hab ich mir irgendwann nach langer Arbeit irgendein System ausgesucht, womit das am besten geht.
Und machst du das jetzt thematisch, oder?
Na ich hab auch noch für die ganzen Label angelegt, für die CDs einzeln oder für irgendwelche Partys.
Labels, CDs?
Was für Label?
Ja, die ganzen V-Pitch Control oder so was.
Achso, du gehst wirklich nach Plattenfirmen? Ja, Plattenlabel. Das heißt, du musst aber doch dann irgendwo eine Datei haben, in der steht, welcher Künstler bei welchem Label ist.
Ja, da gibt es Internetseiten, wo man sich das runterziehen kann.
Das heißt, du brauchst dann aber noch mal irgendwie so einen Index, so einen Katalog, wo denn welcher Künstler wo ist. Okay, das kann man natürlich auch durch Volltextsuche wieder machen. Das geht ja auch ganz gut.
Ja, also ich weiß ja, wo die Musik ist, die ich höre, die weiß ich auch von den 120 Geräten, die ich habe, weiß ich auch mal, wo die ist, also das weiß ich auch aus dem Kopf. Das ist ja nicht schwierig.
Also auf die Idee wäre ich jetzt nicht gekommen, aber es ist natürlich nicht so abhängig.
Das ist nicht schwierig, Moment mal, du hast also verschiedene Verzeichnisse. Das ist ein Verzeichnis für EMI, ein Verzeichnis für Sony Music oder sonst was.
Nein, es ist mehr hauptsächlich Technolabels, und das geht eigentlich. Die meisten kann man immer unterscheiden, weil die Interpreten gehören hauptsächlich nur zu einem Label.
Das heißt aber, du hast im Kopf, welcher Interpret zu welchem Label gehört?
Bei den meisten schon, ja.
Ach so. Aber dafür bräuchte man normalerweise, wenn man es dann ernsthaft archivieren würde, ja noch einen Katalog.
Ja, ich habe, es sind ja auch nicht so viele Label, die ich habe, aber so ein paar.
Der echt große Vorteil ist, wenn du zum Radio spielst, du hast die Label kurz sofort per Hand. Die braucht man nämlich für die Gimmer.
Ja, besten Dank Sabine.
Ja, also ich bin nicht mehr im Serverraum. Ah, eine gute Suppe meinen Serverraum verlassen. Bei den mp3 Geschichten. Also ich verfolge da diese POD-Philosophie, also Point of Data. Also jede CD wird abgelegt nach Interpret-Album. Ganz normal in ein Verzeichnis runter, die kann ich dann auch dementsprechend incrementieren. Ich kann das instrumentell mal sichern, auf die CD runterbrennen, die ganzen mp3-Dateien. Und dann läuft jeden Morgen gegen 6 irgendwie ein Skript, was alle mp3-Tags ausliest und mir halt ein Verzeichnisbaum anlegt, nach Genre, nach Jahr der Erscheinung, nach Interpreten. So erfasse ich dann auch Interpreten, die entsprechend auf irgendwelchen gemischten CDs drauf sind.
Und dieser Baum wird dann mit Swimlinks aufgebaut auf die eigenen Daten?
Also es sind dann irgendwie 250.000 Links, die jeden Morgen erzeugt werden, aber das schnuddelt halt vor sich hin eine dreiviertel Stunde.
Ich hoffe, du hast genug Einhörsachterplatte.
Ja.
Ich hab nicht die leisteste Ahnung, wovon ihr gerade sprecht.
Das ist jetzt die Harald-Variante, die Sachen nicht so genau.
Ja, ich hab das mal geklaut im Linux-Magazin von Paul Meister, der hat sowas aufgebaut. Und die Philosophie war halt genau die, wenn ich schon mal die mp3-Dateien erzeugt habe, möchte ich sie auch mal konsequent sichern, falls mal irgendwie der Super-GAU entsteht, auch wenn ich das auf dem Rad laufen habe. Und so kann ich halt jede Woche mal ein paar CDs wegbrennen oder mal eine DVD jetzt. Und hab halt die mp3-Dateien auf alle Fälle gesichert. Und der Rest passiert über das Auslesen der mp3-Tags.
Das ist alles ganz toll. Versuch noch mal einem Kind zu erklären, was das Besondere an dieser Art zu sichern ist, weil ich hab's nicht verstanden, was ihr da macht.
Also ich glaub, die Idee, der Gedanke dabei ist, dass du...
Point-of-Data-Philosophie ist eigentlich einfach nur die, dass ich irgendwo mir einen Container oder mehrere Container erzeuge. Das Ursprüngliche der Pearlmaster hat es ursprünglich mal halt in 650 Megabyte Brocken einfach weggesichert, so ein Verzeichniserzeug, wo 650 Megabyte mp3-Dateien drin sind. Und das war dann halt eine CD, die hat er weggesichert. Und jetzt, damit kann ich natürlich nichts anfangen, mit einem Verzeichnis, wo einfach 650 Megabyte mp3-Dateien drin sind.
Völlig unsortiert?
Völlig unsortiert, also so, wie ich es erzeugt. Ich mache es halt nach Alben, also ich mache es nicht so, wie er das gemacht hat. Ich meine, ich habe ja am Anfang gut die ersten erste halbe Jahr, aber natürlich unerlaublich viele Daten.
Ist okay, ist okay, bleib beim Thema, bleib auf dem Weg. Erklär mir, wie du deine Daten sichert. Du erzeugst einfach irgendwie mp3s. Die schmeißt du einfach irgendwo in einen Container?
Ja, jede CD kommt in ein Verzeichnis. Die heißt halt Interpret Album. Und wenn es halt ein Sampler ist, dann heißt es Various Artist. Und dann ist da halt...
Wunderbar, du schweifst ab.
Darf ich das vielleicht abkürzen?
Ja, mach mal.
Also die Daten werden einfach einmal irgendwo abgelegt. Und da hast du die Daten liegen und dann hast du beliebig viele Bäume nach irgendwelchen Suchkriterien, wie zum Beispiel Genre, wie zum Beispiel, was auch immer, Erscheinungsjahr. Und das sind dann alles symbolische Links oder auch Verweise, wie die unter anderem mit dem System genommen werden, auf die eigenen Daten.
Also du hast halt nur eine einzelne verschiedene Ansicht auf die Daten.
Aber das macht iTunes auch mit einer schönen Oberfläche.
durch alle Dateien durchliegt, alle MP3 Texte aus und sagt... Ja, ist angekommen. dieses Lied hat den Interpreten und in dem Jahr und liegt halt in entsprechenden Verzeichnisbäumen...
Genau, und der Vorteil dabei ist, es geht auch ohne iTunes.
Danke, Markus. So, und vor Nachrichten noch ein, Karsten.
Hallo, ich wollte zwei Sachen sagen. Erstmal zu den Verzeichnisbäumen. Ich mache fast so ähnlich wie der Markus. Allerdings mache ich das real mit den MP3s. Und zwar sollte ich die einerseits nach langer, der andereseits nach Jahren. Geht natürlich das Risiko ein, dass ich die, also viele MP3s doppelt habe, aber das...
Und dann vielleicht noch alphabetisch?
Nee, alphabetisch nicht. Also alphabetisch stand natürlich in den Genres nach den Albumnamen. Und dann der zweite Diskussionsbeitrag hier, da geht es um die Sicherung. Ich habe zwei Rätsysteme und die werden gespiegelt und wird so alle zwei, drei Wochen abgeglichen. Sodass wenn ein Rechner mal auch gestohlen wird, dann ist der zweite an einem unabhängigen Ort immer noch einsatzbereit. Sodass ich da sehr wenig Risiko habe, dass alle Daten auf einmal verloren gehen.
Was ein Rate ist, erklären wir uns mal, glaube ich, nach den Nachrichten, weil der Griff hier schon häufiger gefallen ist.
Redundant array of independent disks.
Vielen Dank Carsten. Was ich allerdings immer noch nicht verstanden habe, ist, warum irgendeines dieser Systeme, die nicht iTunes sind, besser sein soll als iTunes.
Weil sie unabhängig von jeder williwegen verwendeten Software sind.
Ja, aber das ist doch sowieso. Die Daten liegen doch. Ich meine, du kannst doch genauso, ich kann dir jetzt meine Festplatte geben, dann kannst du im Zweifelsfall, falls mein iTunes mal nicht mehr funktionieren sollte, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, kannst du dein Ding da drüber laufen lassen. Dann funktioniert es ja trotzdem noch.
Nachträglich kann ich es machen, ja.
Ja, aber warum ist das denn so?
Aber du musst sie dann wieder umsortieren. Also ich meine, wenn du mir jetzt deine MP3 ist, dann muss ich mich da jetzt umständlich durchsuchen.
Ach. Ja natürlich, das sind ja meine.
Nee, nee, nee.
Hauptsache anders sein, ne? Der Nr.
3, 2. Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter. Nachts abklingende Schauer bei 7 bis 3 Grad. Am Tag wechselnd bewölkt erneut Schauer bei 12 bis 17 Grad. Eben waren es noch 20. Was ist passiert, Matthias?
Keine Ahnung, das ist jetzt von einer anderen Welle übernommen. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat eine Vereinbarung zwischen Politik und Wirtschaft für mehr Arbeitsplätze angeregt. Diese sollte sich am Ausbildungspakt orientieren. Politik und Wirtschaft stünden gemeinsam in der Verantwortung, für mehr Arbeitsplätze zu sorgen, sagte er. Bundesregierung und Gewerkschaften wollen die Weiterbildung arbeitsloser Jugendlicher verbessern. Dafür soll eine Expertengruppe gebildet werden. DGB-Chef Sommer wies darauf hin, dass allein in Berlin zehnmal mehr Jugendliche in ein Euro Jobs stecken als in Ausbildungsmaßnahmen. Die neue Regierung des italienischen Ministerpräsidenten Berlusconi hat die Vertrauensabstimmung in der Abgeordnetenkammer gewonnen. Für das Kabinett stimmten 334 Abgeordnete. Dagegen fasst die gesamte Mittellinks-Opposition mit 220 Stimmen. Heute findet der fünfte sogenannte Girls Day statt. Über 125.000 Schülerinnen haben sich angemeldet. Sich in bisher typisch männlichen Berufen umzuschauen. Über 6.800 Einrichtungen, von der Werkstatt bis zum Ministerium, öffnen dafür ihre Türen. Auch Fritz ist bei dieser Aktion dabei. Zum Sport noch schnell. Der FC Chelsea muss um den Einzug in das Finale der Champions League bangen. Der designierte englische Fußballmeister musste sich im ersten Halbfinale gegen den Ligakonkurrenten FC Liverpool mit einem 0 zu 0 begnügen. Der Verkehr, Fritz, hat keine aktuellen Meldungen. Wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Matthias. 6 Minuten nach halb eins.
Sonntag ist der 1. Mai. Und er lässt Kenneth M natürlich nicht anbrennen. Im ganzen Satz, wir geben nicht nur Gas, nein, wir halten auch das Tempo. Jan Pletska und Stoppel von Seelig betreiben mit Schauspieler Marek Hartloff die geilste Punk-Ment der Republik. Tempo, Sonntag bei KLFM und weil Erstammer ist, dreht sich natürlich alles um den Rennsport. KenFM, die Fritz-Radioshow mit Ken Jepsen. Jeden Sonntag von 14 bis 18 Uhr.
Live in den Fritz Studios in Potsdam-Abertsberg und im Radio. Chaosradio 101. Nichts ist für die Ewigkeit. Datenspeicherung, Datensicherung, Datensverlust, Datenspeicherung, Sicherung und Verlust. Sehr schön gesagt. Meine Güte, könnt ihr dann mal übernehmen, damit ich nicht noch mehr minstere hin. Wir sind gerade beim Computerspielemuseum angelangt.
Richtig, also wir hatten bisher, wir haben drüber gesprochen, was sind eigentlich Festplatten, wie funktionieren sie, welche Probleme gibt es, warum gehen die Dinger kaputt, was mache ich, kann ich nicht ahnen, wenn die Festplatte kaputt ist, wie bekomme ich meine Daten zurück, warum tippe ich nicht irgendwie wild auf meine Tastatur rum, um mal eben was zu löschen, stellen fest, ich habe aus Versehen alles gelöscht, das kann ich machen, wenn ich alles gelöscht habe, wie sichere ich meine Daten, wie mache ich Backups, wie sinnvoll sind USB-Sticks, wie lange halten Daten auf CDs, ich glaube, die Frage konnten wir nicht so richtig klären, aber das liegt ja auch noch daran.
Was ich ja sehr, sehr interessant fand, war, dass Vic, also jemand, der sich professionell mit Datenlöschung befasst, gesagt hat, dass im Moment das Medium seines größten Vertrauens, der Flaschschweicher, das fand ich wirklich interessant. Also es ging, muss man dazu sagen, nicht um überschreiben, sondern um einmal sichern und für lange Zeit aufheben und wieder sichtbar machen.
Wobei da ist natürlich auch wieder das Problem der Formate, das heißt, da ist auch ein Dateisystem drauf.
Natürlich.
Das war natürlich jetzt, also Standard ist, glaube ich, so FAT, FAT12 oder so, also ein einfaches FAT-System, was also bei MS-DOS, sprich Windows auch verwendet wird.
Da kann man eine Anekdote dazu erzählen. Ja, eine Anekdote dazu. Ja, es ist ja so, wie wir anfangs auch mal erwähnt hatten, als wir die Flash-Speicher behandelt haben, dass die nur eine begrenzte Zahl von Überschreibvorgängen auf der gleichen Speicherstelle erlauben. Also das schwankt so zwischen 10 und 100.000.
Meinst du eigentlich 10.000 und 100.000 oder 10 und 100.000?
Zwischen 10.000 und 100.000. Ich wollte nur sichergehen, da hätte ich echt viel Geld für Mist ausgegeben. Ja, und das ist also so, dass leider dieses antiquierte MS-DOS beziehungsweise PC-DOS-Filesystem FAT bis heute sich durchgesetzt hat auf diesen Medien, weil einfach die ganzen Digitalkameras auch dieses Format speichern und die ganzen MP3-Player nur dieses Format verstehen und so weiter. Und es ist eben so, dass bei dieser Organisation, wie das Datalsystem Datenstrukturen auf dem physischen Medium, also auf diesem Flash-Speicher, ablegt, ist es so, dass bestimmte Cluster, wenn die genannt, also bestimmte Stellen sehr häufig überschrieben werden. Das heißt, wo ich das Inhaltsverzeichnis z.B. habe, der Dateien, da muss, ich weiß nicht, drei oder vier Mal überschrieben werden, jedes Mal, wenn ich eine Datei da drauf kopiere. Das heißt, ich habe also schon drei oder vier solche Überschreibzyklen für jedes Mal, wo ich eine Datei auf diesem Datenträger speicher. Wenn ich lösche, gehen natürlich auch wieder Zyklen drauf. Das heißt, irgendwann würde man sagen, ja gut, diese eine Stelle auf diesem Flash-Speicher, wo dieses Inhaltsverzeichnis steht, die ist sozusagen am schnellsten abgenutzt, da habe ich diese 10:000 am schnellsten erreicht. Die eigentlichen Datensektoren, die sind vielleicht noch gut. Und deswegen sind die neueren Flash-Speicher haben explizit in der Hardware einen Workaround für dieses schlecht entwickelte Filesystem sozusagen. Die entdecken dann automatisch, ah, da sind schon so viele Schreibzyklen gewesen, jetzt remappen wir das mal. Das heißt also, wenn du jetzt sagst, der fünfte Sektor auf diesem Flash-Speicher, dann ist das gar nicht immer der fünfte, sondern der mappt das dann irgendwo anders hin, um sozusagen das zu vermeiden, dass ein bestimmter Sektor zu häufig überschrieben wird.
Da haben wir uns was eingebrockt, als wir damals alle Windows 95 installiert haben.
Ja, so ist das eben mit diesen Flash-Speichern, nicht wahr?
Genau, das war also zumindest mal das, was uns so die letzten zweieinhalb Stunden untergekommen ist. Und wir wollten jetzt, wo es zum Schluss hingeht, nochmal ein paar Spezialfälle bei der Langzeitarchivierung oder bei der musealen Erfassung, Archivierung, Indizierung zurückkommen. Zum einen ist zusätzlich ein zunehmendes Problem, wenn die Daten kopiergeschützt sind, die Medien. Das heißt also, wenn wir jetzt mit, also bei Musik-CDs, das ist ja schon der Fall, da hat, glaube ich, auch Fritz, glaube ich, ein Problem auch damit, um die Sachen in ihren Systemen einzuspielen für die Musik, die dann gespielt wird, auch aus dem Computer, was aber auch natürlich Bibliotheken haben. Das heißt also, das sind dann irgendwelche kopiergeschützten Werke, die die bekommen. Und die haben dann damit zu kämpfen.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wie unser Archiv archiviert. Ich glaube, die archivieren auch nochmal die Original-CD dazu.
Gut, aber so für den täglichen Bedarf.
Für den täglichen Bedarf spielen wir ja aus der Konserve. Wobei wir dann immer noch die Möglichkeit haben, dass dann einfach Audio, also analog quasi.
Aber der Kopierschutz ist ja erstmal, also ich meine, die Sachen werden ja wahrscheinlich nicht analog archiviert. Also die werden ja schon versuchen, CDS zu rippen.
Die rippen die ja.
Genau, und das ist halt blöd, wenn da ein Kopierschutz drauf ist. Also weil dann ist es halt zum einen, zwar wäre es theoretisch illegal, wenn da nicht irgendwie noch so ein Rundfunkprivileg irgendwie wäre, was den es erlaubt wohl irgendwie. Das ist auch eine interessante Frage, ob es das gibt vielleicht. Und die Bibliotheken kämpfen im Moment gerade mit den Verlagen, vor allem also gerade von Datenbanken, von wissenschaftlichen Datenbanken, von juristischen Datenbanken, dass da spezielle Versionen an die Bibliotheken geben werden oder dass die Bibliotheken sogar die Erlaubnis bekommen, die gesetzliche Erlaubnis bekommen, diesen Kopierschutz zu knacken, zu umgehen, für die Zwecke, das eben nutzbar zu machen in der Bibliothek. Was natürlich ein Problem ist, wenn ich Sachen einlagern will, dann brauch ich auch immer das Programm, um die Sachen abzuspielen. Ich brauch einen speziellen Player. Wenn ich jetzt einen kopiergeschützten CD hab, dann brauch ich unter Umständen einen speziellen Player oder irgendwelche DRM-Werke. Wenn ich mir die im Online-Shop hole, dann laufen die eben nur mit dem Windows-Media-Player. Aber wenn es seit einem Grund in drei Jahren keinen Windows mehr gibt und keinen Media-Player, dann hab ich ein Problem. Vor allem in 30 Jahren. Ich hab halt deine Musik, ich hab die auf meinem Computer und kann sie dann nicht mehr abspielen. Und das ist damit wertlos. Und ich kann dann die Lizenzen, wenn ich jetzt irgendwelche Lizenzen brauche, um die Musik abzuspielen zu nutzen, und ich krieg sie einfach nirgendswo mehr her und die sind meinetwegen zeitlich begrenzt für eine Woche oder für einen Monat, dann hab ich da ein Problem. Dürfen wir jetzt wieder? Ach so. Mach uns mal ein bisschen leiser. Nee, die Musik leiser.
Wunderbar, dann können wir weiter reden. Interessanter wird es dann natürlich, wenn es vor allem auch in Richtung multimediale Werke geht, also jetzt irgendwelche Flash-Animationen oder in Macromedia Director oder was auch immer es für tolle Tools gibt, wo man irgendwelche multimedialen Werke oder interaktive Filme und was nicht alles schaffen kann. Diese Formate sind ja auch wieder alle sehr spezifisch. Das heißt also, um diese multimedialen Werke noch so erfahrbar oder benutzbar zu machen, in Zukunft brauche ich dann auch die entsprechende Abspielsoftware und die entsprechende Hardware, auf der diese Software läuft, damit das überhaupt erhalten werden kann.
Ein Spezialfall davon sind Computerspiele. Da gibt es also mehrere Projekte, um so was zu archivieren. Oder wenn ihr einfach ein Computerspiel von einem C64, so die Dinger gibt es nicht mehr zu kaufen. Es gibt sie noch auf dem Trödelmarkt. Ich kann sie mir noch irgendwie. Es gibt Emulatoren mittlerweile dafür. Aber es gibt halt teilweise sehr, sehr obscure Computersysteme, vielleicht wo spezielle Spiele gab oder Spielekonsolen. Und mittlerweile ist aber auch schon die Einsicht da, dass man so Sachen einfach aufheben will, dass das irgendwie kulturgut ist, was irgendwie bewahrt werden muss. Und weißt nicht, hast du da irgendwelche speziellen, also gibt es da irgendwelche nennenswerten Projekte zu?
Du bekommst ja irgendwann auch das Problem, also wo willst du die ganze Hardware hinstellen?
Na, es gibt doch sogar hier in Berlin das Computerspielemuseum.
Es gibt ein Computerspielemuseum, genau.
Das, was hier auch in dem Bereich tätig ist. Und mit der Emulation, die du gerade angesprochen hast, ist ja auch immer so eine Sache. Das kann ich vielleicht mit dem C64 machen. Aber jetzt irgendwie, ich kann ja, also Emulation heißt ja, dass ich sozusagen komplette Hardware von einem System in Software nachbaue.
PS2 Emulator, ne?
Jaja, sicher. Das geht vor allem, je einfacher die Hardware war, umso einfacher kann ich es natürlich auch emulieren. Und die Hardware wird immer komplexer. Also dass ich dann irgendwann mal, was weiß ich was, für eine Spielekonsole, die jetzt gerade so aktuell ist auf dem Markt, dass ich die dann auf einmal vollständig emuliere, das wird dann schon schwieriger in Zukunft werden. Und vor allem brauche ich natürlich auch entsprechend mehr Rechenleistung. Und dann kommt eben dazu noch die Sache mit irgendwelchen Kopierschutzmechanismen, Digital Restrictions Management, was auch immer. Also es ist mit Sicherheit ein ziemlich anspruchsvolles Problem, das so zu archivieren und auch spielbar zu erhalten. Es gibt auch andere Ansätze jetzt im Bereich der Computerspiele, wo man dann nicht die komplette System oder diese Spielekonsole, was auch immer, emuliert, sondern wo man sozusagen die Game Engine reimplementiert. Das gibt es für die Leute, die sowas wie Space Quest und King's Quest und die LucasArts Adventures, also so many mentioned, Zack McCracken, Indie 3, Indie 4 und so weiter, die das noch kennen. Für die beiden Engines, die hinter dem Spiel sitzen, also einmal diese Sierra und einmal die LucasArts Schiene, da gibt es Reimplementationen, die laufen unter Mac OS, unter Windows, unter Linux und so weiter. Das heißt, ich kann mir die alten Daten von den alten Disketten oder was auch immer runterholen und muss aber jetzt nicht irgendwie meinen alten 286 mit MS-DOS auspacken, damit ich das starten kann, sondern ich kann eben einfach ein aktuelles Linux oder Windows oder Mac OS Programm verwenden, um das eben auszuführen. Das ist aber dann auch wieder die Spiele-Fan-Community, die sozusagen solche Sachen macht und das neu implementiert. Das ist aber eher der Ausnahmefall.
Wobei natürlich da auch wieder, es gibt juristische Probleme dabei, das heißt, also die Sachen, die dann urheberrechtlich geschützt haben, ich darf sie halt nicht re-engineeren oder habe einfach bestimmte Begrenzungen. Also, ja, das ist halt eine heikel Sache. Also gerade auch, wenn wir jetzt über diese Kopierschutzgeschichten sprechen, das heißt, welche Grenzen gibt es da eigentlich oder wann darf ich was archivieren? Das sind so Sachen, wo ich zumindest, wenn ich das professionell machen will, das heißt also auch für die Öffentlichkeit wirklich angelegte Sachen, mit denen ich mich hier noch auseinandersetzen muss.
Ja, das ist richtig. Wobei für die für das Re-Engineering, da gibt es immer diese schöne Ausnahme, dass zu Zwecken der Interoperabilität darfst du das auch ohne Zustimmung des Rechteinhabers machen. Und was du bei diesen Spielen ja auch ganz eindeutig, also du willst es ja, um dieses Spiel noch mit modernen Rechnern überhaupt zum Funktionieren zu bringen. Also das kann man da denke ich schon argumentieren. Aber es ist einfach irgendwie auch, wie soll ich sagen, ein Unding, dass hier Leute in ihrer Freizeit als Enthusiasmus Dinge neu implementieren, nur weil die Hersteller sozusagen nicht in der Lage sind oder es sich nicht für wichtig halten, sozusagen irgendwie eine Archivierung ihrer alten Produkte möglich zu machen und die nach wie vor benutzbar zu halten.
Was ich mir ja noch wünschen würde so gegen Ende der Sendung, ist, könnt ihr mir nicht vielleicht doch noch mal Raid erklären? Ihr habt es angekündigt, dass wir es machen.
Genau, wir machen es auch. Genau, also die Idee bei Raid, wie der Name auch schon sagt, fürchterlich komplizierter Redundant Array of Independence ist. Genau, und die Idee dabei ist, dass man kleinere Festplatten, die relativ günstig sind, zusammensteckt, sinnvoll zusammensteckt und darüber einen logischen Datenträger macht. Das heißt, ich fasse die sinnvoll zusammen und kann dann bei mehr oder weniger Datensicherheit auch noch einbauen. Beziehungsweise kann die so optimieren, dass wenn die Daten parallel gespeichert werden, also nicht parallel, sondern über zwei Festplatten, dass dann der Datenzugriff schneller ist. Das ist die Idee dabei. Es gibt also verschiedene RAID-Stufen, verschiedene Levels. Das ist eine Wissenschaft für sich, welche dann jeweils für die konkrete Anwendung die beste ist. Aber die Idee ist, dass ich halt mehrere kleinere Festplatten zu einem großen Super-Datenträger zusammenfasse.
Das ist grundsätzlich die Idee bei RAID. Der RAID-Level sagt dann eben aus, was ich da mache. Ich kann RAID 0 fahren. Da werden die Daten verteilt auf die einzelnen Platten. Ich habe keine Redundanz drin. In RAID steckt ja eigentlich dieses Redundant drin. Man möchte Redundanz in den Daten schaffen, um auch ausfallsicherer zu sein zum Beispiel. RAID 0 erfüllt dieses Kriterium Redundant nicht, weil ich einfach nur die Daten auf zwei Festplatten verteile. Da habe ich keine Redundanz, sondern ich habe halt einfach zwei Festplatten mit 100 Gigabyte und dann habe ich eine neue virtuelle, die hat 200 Punkt. Bei RAID 1, das ist das komplette Gegenteil, da wird eine vollständige Spiegelung gemacht. Das heißt, ich habe zwei Platten zu je 100 Gigabyte und ich spiegel die. Das heißt, ich habe eine neue virtuelle Platte, die hat auch nur 100 Gigabyte. Dafür kann ich mir aber sicher sein, dass alles doppelt gespeichert ist. Und wenn eine der beiden Platten kaputt geht, dann habe ich immer noch die andere. Und da gibt es dann noch bessere und fortschrittlichere Level. Rate 5 ist auch noch am häufigsten mitgebraucht in dem Zusammenhang. Da mache ich das dann eben über Prüfsummen und verteile die über die Platten. Das heißt, ich nehme zum Beispiel sechs Platten und von diesen sechs Platten kann eine ausfallen und ich habe immer noch alle Daten. Also die Daten werden so geschickt verstreut und verteilt und mit Prüfsummen versehen, dass man hier eben beim Entfallen einer Platte sozusagen, dass den Inhalt dieser Platte noch durch Rechenoperationen und den Inhalt der anderen Platten errechnen kann. Wenn die zweite ausfällt, dann geht es nicht mehr. Also da ist dann wieder die Grenze vorgeschoben. Also im professionellen Bereich erkennt man das schon seit langer Zeit und macht das seit Jahren, Jahrzehnten wahrscheinlich schon fast. Im privaten Bereich wird es jetzt auch aufgrund der günstigen Verfügbarkeit von Festplatten häufiger mal eingesetzt. Also wer größere Sammlungen hat, der wird schon auch mal irgendwie so ein Rate 0 oder sowas machen oder wer auf Datensicherheit wert liegt, macht dann eben ein Rate 1 und ist sich dann sicher gut, wenn eine Platte ausfällt, dann geht es halt immer noch.
Und diese Rate Controller sind auch einigermaßen bezahlbar geworden, wobei da muss man also auch aufpassen, was man da kauft. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich fehlt noch mal eine extra Sendung. Es gibt also die sehr günstigen, die eigentlich nicht so viel machen, wo zwar Rate drauf steht, wo aber eigentlich nicht wirklich viel passiert, wo der Computer den meisten Part übernehmen muss, was dann auch wieder ein bisschen Performance-Einbuße ist.
In aller Regel für den privaten Bereich ist ein Rate Controller sowieso überdimensioniert. Also Rate Controller heißt, dass ich eine spezielle Hardware habe, die diese Verteilung auf mehrere Platten übernimmt. Und das kann ich aber genauso gut in Software machen. Also eigentlich alle Betriebssysteme, egal ob jetzt Windows oder Linux oder Mac OS, die können eben zumindest die gängigen Rate Level machen von Haus aus. Und dann stechst du einfach in der Software ein, dann wird das in der Software gemacht. Der Aufwand, der da mehr an Belastung für den Prozessor da ist, der ist nicht wirklich relevant auf einem privaten PC.
Ja, ich möchte mal hinweisen auf unsere Mitmachseite in der Wikipedia. Die ist verlinkt von unserer Homepage von chaosradio.ccc.de. Da steht auch noch mal alles drin zu den Streams, zu unseren Sendungen, was wir so gemacht hatten bisher an Themen. Da steht auch noch mal eine Kontaktadresse drin und eben sehr link zu der Mitmachseite. Da haben jede Menge Leute schon eingetragen, vielen Dank dafür. Wir werden es auch ein bisschen nachbearbeiten. Mal sehen, wie viel wir das noch so schaffen. Aber wir werden auf jeden Fall sehen, dass wir da auch ein paar Sachen aus der Sendung noch mit einstellen. Da sind auch die meisten Links drin, mit der wir die Seiten nun vorbereitet haben. Ein bisschen die Struktur, was wir so erzählt haben. Und wir haben auch schon eine ganze Menge Anregungen von da, denke ich, auch übernommen. Und ja, bis in einem Monat.
Vielleicht auch noch, wenn wir gerade bei der WGP da sind, wir haben auch noch eine generelle Mitmachseite, wo man Themenvorschläge einbringen kann. Wer also sich unbedingt mal an Chaosradio über das Thema...
Ja, wir gucken uns die tatsächlich auch an und wir wählen da auch mal Vorschläge aus.
Genau, wie zum Beispiel die Sendung 100.
Richtig, die letzte Sendung.
Ja, also viel Spaß beim Mitmachen.
Und vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Chaosradio 102 am letzten Mittwoch im Februar, das ist der 25.2.
Was denn?
Was guckst du mich so komisch an?
Der 25.2.
Februar? Hab ich Februar gesagt?
2004?
Ja genau, genau 2004. Natürlich ist das, das ist dann der 24.5. Ruft einen Arzt! Na, ihr wisst schon, also das nächste Chaosradio, also Chaosradio 102 am letzten Mittwoch des Monats, der auf den Monat folgte, dem ihr Chaosradio 101 gehört habt. Also nächsten Monats. Also ungefähr ein Jahr und ich. Mahlzeit!